Film Courage: Van, 10 years ago you told
your wife you wanted to be a filmmaker.
What was going on in your life at that time?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker: I woke up one day
10 years ago and shocked her by going hey I
think I want to make movies and she was like what
what do you mean what are you talking about and
I think what was going on in my life was I just
I was a photographer at the time and I just loved
stories and at the time I was telling stories of
one frame then I was like oh be interesting if I
just could could write a story write a movie
and I didn't know what the first thing about
what making a movie is all about and I wasn't even
one that watched a lot of movies and she was the
one she was one in the in our relationship that
watched movies and but I wanted to tell stories
and and so I like went to amazon no I went to the
to this place in in Dallas it's called half-price
books and I would buy as many books I could about
screenwriting or movies or what directors wrote
and I would just read that and get my hands on
as much scripts as I could and I spent the next
like year or two just writing and and that
at that time the the dslr camera came about
and canon came out and you start doing great
videos and I was like oh this isn't and that
seemed like a natural transition from being
a photographer now it could be a videographer
so that was sort of the the start
of at all my kind of desire to like
change things up tell more stories in a different
way and then she and she was like oh my gosh
you just started your photography
career and it's going good
why don't you open up a restaurant
too and do everything that's like
like percentage-wise difficult to do and so I
just I just became disciplined and woke up each
morning and tried to write write a sentence
so and then 10 years later you got to film
and previously were you an early riser or
was this a new routine you were getting into
I think I'm I think I'm personally an early riser
especially with writing there's there's a for me
personally I fi I find that from six to nine a.m
there's a I write best there that time and it's
a struggle after nine a.m so the I think it's
because I get up right away everything's quiet
and if something's brilliant that night before I
have a better clarity of it some people work at
different hours but I just found over the years
that was my sweet spot because I think it felt
like alone that nothing could could bother me
and I didn't want to be on the computer and I
could be quiet and things like that so that
was my my sweet spot though I don't wake up
at six every every morning it just depends if I'm
working on a project I i would get up that early
well don't feel bad charles bukowski
would start at noon yeah yeah okay
but what do you think happens after 9 00 a.m
is it just something mental in your brain I
think it's because a couple hours of our I
think what happens especially for me I was
because your brain's always like trying to solve
problems solve like what does this character
have what's the story what's happening so it's
almost like you're constantly doing a rubik's
cube and not getting one side done and that's how
I always felt so after three or four hours there's
fatigue I think for me so I would take
a break or I would just force myself
to work on something and I took it kind
of seriously because I i didn't I think
I got tired of not taking in everything else so
not seriously in my life I was like what would
what would I wake up each day that I would enjoy
and try to get better at and and and writing was
something that was personal for me that that no
one could take away so I didn't have to wait for
a producer or or an actor or if I was in a band
I didn't have to wait for the drummer or the
basis or I could just get up and write and I think
that was so freeing and that's what I enjoyed
enjoyed about the idea of writing a script versus
a novel a script in my head was like 100 page poem
and I always wanted to be a poet for some reason
and I knew that each word had a lot to it that
you can't waste waste the word or space
so that's that's how I think I got better
my scripts weren't so tight they were just on
these things but I think now 10 years later they
I cliches are correct for a reason they keep
saying like kill your babies like what's that mean
I was like oh that's such a great line or a great
scene a great dialogue and like ah it just doesn't
fit you just kind of kind of you gotta knock it
out and I got a little bit better of not crying
when I have to kill my own little baby babies
but writing is something I enjoy so waking up
each morning I get excited for that but then I'm
not a robot so I get fatigued and tired out does
something have to have meaning like an intense
meaning for you to want to take time to do it um
i think yeah I think so it had to mean something
for me or something for me to investigate
but I think as I get older I'm really
investigating myself I think that's what I'm
trying to find even with these stories with all
these different characters it's I think it's like
it's a way of me trying to understand what when
I'm about and again that's very ego driven being
a director in this is oh like this but but I think
I'm trying to see how I relate into this world and
and and what what inspires me what makes me
scared what makes me happy and and if I have
a certain feeling I just hope there's another
human being that possibly possibly might have
the same feeling so that's how your work might
be able to connect I think if someone out there
feels the same way and that's all you could hope
for as any artist is try to get what you what you
have in your brain your heart out and then if it
comes out correctly maybe someone might understand
that and climbing the corporate ladder is ego
driven too so that artists get a bad rap and
writers and and I understand that there's a lot of
internal stuff that comes out in people's work but
people climbing a corporate ladder also oh yeah
I was talking to a friend who he was scientists
prior to becoming a filmmaker and he was like the
the the cutthroat world of of being in being a
scientist and getting that research grant getting
this taking credit for certain findings and things
it's just another thing hey that might be a movie
idea wow yeah that's true black swan of yeah
science world from the moment that you
told your wife you wanted to be a filmmaker
what immediate changes did you make in your life
in terms of craft or trying to understand it was
reading and studying everything I could about
about writing about how how it's structured or
how people how you format and just the basics
of things so I kind of took it as my own way of
going go making my own school of like I want to
learn this this is this is interesting I just
can't write on a napkin or or legal pad I just
wanted to see that I guess I could but I i didn't
so the changes I made was was really making a
commitment to trying to get better at it it wasn't
a thing that I said this is going to be a career
it was a thing that was like I just wanted to do
it so I didn't know if it was even going to be
something feasible that that didn't even cross
my mind I just it gave me something that I could
wake up and and do and challenge myself and and
that I think I just never reached a point where
I was frustrated enough to quit I think that was
that was what the screen ran because obviously
once you have a script then you needed to
you know produce the thing so you have
to shoot the thing and then I think
I just got I just try to do it off because
it seemed fun call call my friends up or
my family and go hey could you just come could
we just spend this weekend and then we and and do
this and and then that's how it all began just
to see if I could do it from start to finish
so and then when I did a short film it was fun it
was I liked the whole process the storyboarding
the getting people together mapping things
out and and and seeing the words come alive
from from actors or or family members I
don't know I would call them actors but but
they were gracious enough to help me out so
you said previously you went to a bookstore
that was in texas sorry was it in Dallas or where
it was yeah Dallas it was half it's called half
price books which which people would sell back
their books and and that you could get all these
books for really really cheap and and things
like that so I i would buy a whole bunch of
like books about directors books on I think I got
that Robert Rodriguez book there the the rebel
book and then I got a couple other tons of other
things and then then I was searched for scripts
scripts online to read thank goodness
for the internet you I mean it's like
you could just get anything you
want and and and and that's what I
that's what helped me you know just trying to
get learn and learn and learn and get better
were there other writers in the Dallas area or was
that something that was not part of the culture
at that time there's I've always had I always
wish I was able to be more gregarious or open
get involved more of the the community or
specifically the film community or theater
I i just didn't wasn't able to do
that at that point because I think
I didn't know where I was headed myself so I
just started just to write I think it was such an
isolating and freeing thing but I i really didn't
meet too many other filmmakers at the time because
I didn't think I was one I was just trying to
write right and and and figure it all out I sort
of did the same thing with my photography career
and there's many ways where you you could go you
could become an assistant you can do this I just
called myself wrote a business plan and called
myself a photographer and shot as many things
as I can weddings and and things I could and and
figure out lighting and and and all that kind
of stuff and then I think I work better that way
it might not be the right way but it at least
I could kind of like know understand understand
what I'm doing wrong but I i oftentimes I wish
I did have a mentor a group and go hey what's my
second act sucks why am I why am I always drowning
in this and they could say you don't have this
there's not a defined goal there's this blah blah
blah blah but I was really honest because if you
read a script like ordinary people if you read a
script like leaving las vegas and then you read
your script you got to be sort of honest and go
that's not close yet you got to work on that why
why how come I can't why am I turning each page
like these other scripts that I love and that
was the same thing when I was a photographer
and when I looked at photos in the magazines
I had to go I to be a photographer or a working
photographer the hard truth is my photos
have to look as good or better than this so until
I was able to do that and gain the confidence
I was just hard on myself in that
way so I just got to get better
whether it took two days or two years or 15 or
10 I was ready to put in put in that because
I don't know why you just kind of like keep going
because you wanted to get better I think so I
took the same approach with with filmmaking and
screenwriting I i wanted to write scenes that that
made me turn the page myself yeah do you think
it's okay to just not be part of a group there's
a lot of pressure especially in western culture to
be part of a group and join something and do all
that and that's great some people really rise to
the occasion I think some people are better just
by themselves internally yeah that's a great I
think it's up to your personality and I think
you need to find that balance it's like sort
of like dieting I guess it's like you can't do
one extreme especially with filmmaking writing
itself is so alone but the filmmaking process
is so collaborative so you need to work with other
others and be be able to do that so so that's what
I wanted to do I wasn't wanted to strictly be
a writer I wanted to work with other people but
I love the isolation of the writing process but
now I've learned the the beauty of rewriting and
and and the input of other people and and and
and getting notes and and getting go hey this is
you got to you got to get into the to it faster
you got to do this oh this is maybe not so so
so right for the for the story so I like I like
taking notes because it it get it gets me to think
of other things because when you're writing for
a script it could take you three six months four
months whatever you're so alone and that maybe
that's why other people have writing partners so
you could bounce ideas but to get notes it gives
me an idea oh I never thought about that let me
plug that in and maybe I could come up with
something else it's pretty freeing for me
to to do that and not take it personal and and
and maybe I'm just more optimistic that go like
people are telling you this not because they
don't want you to make a crappy story it's
because they think it could help and it's your
job to synthesize all that information and see if
it does I think that's that's what happens that's
even being a director because you get like so much
information and so many decisions you have to
make and you have to make it within split seconds
sometimes hey is this makeup too heavy hey what's
the color of that clothes or is this location work
on are we going to do another take does this the
actor feel safe I think it just happens so much so
you really have to be on your toes and and
be adaptable I think I think that that's a
a vital skill even for screenwriters is to
be adaptable and to take to take notes well
and feedback criticism feedback criticism and
go just get back to work and and take it and
what you could do it you make a version of the
notes you could do it and if you don't like it
you go back to the previous version and continue
that way but at least you shouldn't have a
if you follow that process for that for at
least for me I wouldn't have a writer's block
because someone gave you a a door go to this door
it might might not be the right door but you get
to go through it so you could write that out it
doesn't fit I didn't feel right or maybe maybe
I'm missing that scene we need to add that scene
in again so it's interesting process it's it's
definitely sculpting it's you could continuously
keep writing it's it's weird something maybe it's
it's funny just to drop the pin and stop writing
it because I can I could I'll re-read this re-read
the script constantly or the first page the
first line and go I gotta stop and I'm a little
obsessive now I take a break and even the rhythms
I would read it out loud the feel of the words
flow right so that's that's what I because I would
imagine if I was a reader if I was reading this
and if it's boring or or that exposition is too
long or the state or the scene heading is too long
I need to cut that out so that's that's sort
of my process lately is cutting cutting cutting
I think that's being an editor because
I edit as well so you get used to
cutting cutting pieces together looking back
on it now do you think you made the right
choice for yourself choosing the filmmaking path
knowing that you wanted to challenge yourself it
sounds like you you don't compete with others you
kind of are very much about challenging yourself
maybe I'm wrong if I if I think about it and I I'm
very lucky to be able to make that choice and and
feel like it is the right choice certainly it's
it's not the easiest of paths to take it's it's
it's not like if you go to get your bachelor's and
you get your master's or phd and then you you do
your residency and you just your and you pass a
license that you're going to be a psychologist
there isn't like routes and and there isn't
a structure that even determines that you are
so there's well there was blind
faith I think it just more of like
you do something and then you get obsessed about
it and you do everything you can to make it happen
I think that's just what happened what happened
to me and filmmaking ended up being a medium
I was drawn to because I i kind of failed
at everything else I i was I wanted to be
a musician and that didn't work out I want to be
a writer that I didn't that that didn't work out
and I and I i was got into photography and
I got this and I was like wow you could
combine that on that's what filmmaking was
called I never even knew that was possible
so once I knew that the possibilities of it
it maybe I felt like a kid again I was like
so I think that's what drove me in in in
telling a story visually with music with sound
that that was I was hook line and sinker and and
and coming up coming up with stories each time and
developing that and then now working with actors
working with art department working with the crew
you're like whoa this is awesome you you asked
me before about being isolated but now you get to
get out of your hibernation and then play
play with everyone I think that's the fun
part about filmmaking and I think you said just
off camera you knew what you didn't want and so
yeah that's a yeah exactly exactly I i was
very good at good at that I was i'd maybe not
didn't know what I want but I knew what I
didn't want and that's the same thing with like
if I compose something in a frame I know I
didn't want that in the frame I don't want
that in a frame so so what is it that that's left
in the frame so I took this sim similar approach
I didn't want this to happen I didn't
want to have regrets I didn't want to
because I did I had those before I wasted time
I wasted this I didn't have confidence I didn't
have these things and and so when I started like
you asked I just started one day at a time to
see if I enjoyed it and then if I didn't
I probably would have been obsessed with
making ramen noodles that would be the next thing
how do you make those news how do I get it right
right texture oh is this broth right okay then
you want to sell it then you want to do it so I
probably would have been obsessed with something
else if I didn't fall like in love with filmmaking
at what point in this journey did you begin your
production company early on so once you sort of
started the short films and things like that
I just my first short film was called balloons
go pop and then so I started go pop films and and
that started with the short films that I was I was
doing and and then when we embarked on making the
feature film we partner up with red productions
and which is based in fort worth texas and
santa monica and then and then recently
we started a commercial division of rep
representing different commercial directors
for for that so it was a slope process it was
me all the way back then and then just learning
the business of things and then
going hey if this person could start
a production company what's stopping me
from legal paperwork things like that so
so that's that's exactly on the path and I wanted
to have something I could control as a business
can you talk about the process for starting your
business like step by step what did you do yeah so
it depends on obviously if you start out first if
if it's just by yourself for people out there not
knowing you could you could be a sole proprietor
so you don't have to you could you don't have to
start an llc we I eventually
moved into go pot films as an llc
to gain the protection of that but with
that in mind there's different fees involved
state fees different taxes and
things like that involved so
being like a producer versus like a director
or anyone like that you you have to sort of
be on top of the legal regulations
the taxes and things like that
so when you start like your production company
whether it's a commercial production company
you start charging people on fees producing
video content editing and then and then you
would charge that then that'll be your revenue for
the year and you minus all your expenses and then
at first I was doing like all my taxes and
things and then you want to find a good
good accountant after a while it gets a little bit
hairy and things like that and for those who are
maybe starting a film or a movie or a future film
we we had our films called all roads to perrla
prior to that it was called sleeping plastic we
started a sleeping plastic llc so the film itself
is its own entity separate from go pop films
so each film that you'll make will have its own
life so that's sort of the progression of that
of that so I had this idea that wow okay I'll
have go pop films and we'll do films we'd do short
films and hopefully get into future films and then
had this other great idea because I
was trying to get into the commercial
world of of of directing and video and then
instead of being in other people's rosters
oh why don't I create my own commercial vision
and and and put and collect talent that I think
are that have a great voice and and
and professional and could deliver
video content and and and start started that
way so I liked the producing part after I did
after I was produced the first feature film I
was like oh this is a pain in the butt but you
learn so much then you almost like don't wanna
for me I always like I like producing I think
it became it was fun to put things together to
help a director help their vision come alive with
this with the constraint of the budget and that's
that's that's the key I was lucky to work with red
sanders and derek derek brown from red productions
when I first met them they're like man how can we
help you make your your vision and I was like that
wow everyone else they were very honest about that
and I remember derek brown was like that's
part about being a good producer is helping
the director get their vision out there
come alive and and that's what I would like
to do with other filmmakers has helped them get
their vision alive so I love that aspect too
did you form the llc's yourself or did you use a
lawyer or some type of legal service oh legalizing
legal zoom right there is it's pretty pretty easy
that's that's what we did for go pop films yeah
and and then for the the movie as well no for the
movie red productions of red entertainment and us
we had a a lawyer on because the the I believe are
because we were shooting in in oklahoma and texas
so we we had a couple different kind of more
kind of the more more complicated things so we
read red had a lawyer that he always used for
their their films so we went with the same
one for because this this would would have
been their seventh film that they've done
our film so I was going with them it's
like it's I think that's the funniest of
the thing I've learned is this whole like
industry I've learned is it's about leverage
it's kind of interesting when I was starting
and and trying to push the script around and
they would go oh you haven't done a feature
film before it's all you have this is all
about execution you got could you execute this
can you do that and then then once once I was
fortunate enough to work with red productions
who've done all these great films before
you know I was able to work with that's like
playing with someone who is better at you
in tennis so you get better so those these
last three or four years working with all
these people was was a dream because it was I
was still absorbing and learning on what this
industry is about what's producing about what's
the legal work what's how do you get things done
it's like like being a director is is different
being a producer you can't have a sustainable
career if you don't make your investors money back
being a director even though you the movie might
not be a financial success but it might garner
some accolades your career could keep keep going
so the producer's role is really it's brutal you
have it's strictly business you gotta you gotta
make your investors money back and that's a
different different mindset so I love both
all the challenges of it what's one thing that was
a surprise whether it was the paperwork forming
the llc talking to the attorney that you were
so glad that you'll always take with you moving
forward that maybe was a surprise whether it was
you didn't know when the fees for the llc were do
like just different things which I know those kind
of things when you get an irs letter coming at you
that's a big surrounding yeah yeah well it took
out the bone down yeah yeah so you don't want to
mess with the irs so the surprises there's always
a surprise the surprises if you get used to um
learning if you get used to your mistakes and
but don't repeat them I think that's that's great
because no I mean you could go to all these great
schools like producing and or business schools
and learn a lot of things but it's something not
being like trenches and go oh my gosh that 800 fee
it's what's today october 15th this has to be in
it's like so oh did the actors do we get the the
the agreements done what the the agents come and
talk and did we get this sign so the surprise is
get everything in writing sign everything it's all
business there's a reason that's why it's called
the movie business not the movie let's
make vans art it's it's it's it's
you gotta enjoy that aspect of it but if
you love storytelling and how to kind of
play the play and learn the rules of the movie
business and and then I think you'll enjoy it
great yeah yeah no no one wants to get a letter
yeah no one wants to get a letter from the irs and
then and that's one of those things where you want
to call right away yeah even if you're on hold for
two hours yeah it's one yeah it's it's all those
things and there's fees and they and they'll just
keep keep going so the things I get I guess
the thing that surprised me probably is uh
once you think you have it all sent and done
there's always something else oh there's like I
thought we did that then the deliverables didn't
get deliver that or then wasn't that signed or
what do you mean it's like you have to be you
have to be very thorough yeah when you formed
your production company did you take out a
loan to purchase equipment yeah so when we
when I first started before on the equipment
was on just like your dslr on cameras your your
your sound lights and everything so it
was it was credit cards those credit cards
I did I didn't do a per like a personal
loan and this was like 10 years ago 10
plus years ago yeah and then but then as you get
more involved and what what's going when we've
switched from sole proprietor to llc that's
when we you you had investors in in in the
company so then and then you had capital and
equity and things like that that you have to
sort out but I i was just like any other small
business owner with it with their dream and and
credit cards that's it's a rough
rough game I i had a friend who who
opened up this bar with eight nine credit cards
and it became the most popular bar like it won
like most popular bar in the world like like
couple years back it's called employees only
and and I remember way back when and they
had this dream and they did it it's not
a good start but it was the only start I
had because I wanted I wanted to do it and I
i didn't have like I didn't go to the bank
and go hey I need fifty thousand dollars to
start this I didn't go to small business loans
I kept my overhead low that's the thing so then
once you have start having jobs then you could pay
things out so the key is keeping your overhead low
which means don't be straddled with with
rent payroll if I would spend on anything I
didn't spend that much on on equipment I spent
more on marketing I would do that because so
that's what I would would we still do yeah don't
be late with that credit card payment because
oh yeah twenty nine dollar late fee then yeah
and then you get a call eight o'clock on a sunday
morning yeah I'm gonna speak to van please yeah
yeah exactly yeah and yeah you asked that question
like is it was it the right path it's the
path of an entrepreneur I think there's
there's an inherent stress that no one sort of
talks about all the time of whether whether it's
whether it's your credit cards whether
it's your investors whether it's
getting distribution I'm going to get in
this film festival I'm going to get that
after all years of this you've come comfortable
being uncomfortable so you you start to also
become smarter and become a better business
person I always love it when I see signs that
says been in business since 1984 I've been in c
it's like that's awesome how hard is this maintain
any business there's a stretch amount of time
whether you're shining shoes or this it's the
same thing with them like getting a movie so I
kind of had to tell myself to take a chill pill
and take one day at a time or I'm going to get
an ulcer and a goiter if I keep worrying about
the are we going to get in this film festival I'm
going to do that are we going to do this it's like
then you sit back it's like okay if
you do then what if you do then what
it all comes to back down to why did you start
10 years ago I love writing I love doing this so
I always wanted to try to tell myself to not make
something I love an albatross so I have to really
remind myself of that every time so okay is this
what you want to do okay get better don't don't be
don't become cynical things like that how many
people were involved when you started your
production company and then now how many people
are involved when I started it was me and my wife
and now it is me with one two like four other
folks and a whole bunch of interns and and a
roster of really great creatives and directors so
so it's become like a little a little group and
and I'm very fortunate of that to to find
on teammates who who want to go through the
battlefield battlefield of being part of a
production company so we started out small as just
like anyone like I'll be sitting out there going
how do people do it what do you have to do so
I just started it didn't worry about the
equipment if there was a bigger job to do
we would rent rent it I didn't want to buy 20
30 40 000 worth of equipment and have it sit
there for a year to let it depreciate and not
get its value so so now everything's taking a
hit now with with the pandemic even we have that
we also have a sales a sales rep that represents
go pop films and directors in the midwest and
southeast so what they do is they pitch the
ad agencies and art directors on our roster
of directors and they will send if there are
treatments or spots or things that we could
bid on so things like that we also go to
direct to brand or director companies that that
need video content but at the moment just things
are obviously production is that holding it's
picking up but you want to be safe and we and
that's the key key low overhead keep your overhead
so you so you could maintain and sustain so when
when the economy and when comes up you you'll be
able to position yourself so if we think about it
right now as we are in pre-production that's
how I've we've talked about it is like we're
in pre-production so when production comes we're
ready to ready to go so like being able to service
service our clients and things like that to our
best of our ability I think that's where we're at
right now pandemic error right and just just with
other booms and busts like let's say the dot-com
when things were really good in the 90s it also
can you talk about not getting maybe too confident
knowing that there will be a winter and there's
always a winter yeah I think the the life cycle
the life cycle of of things and that you just
have to kind of be steady and and and know
especially with with this you might have a lot of
clients or maybe your business has one big client
but what if they just what if they disappear what
if your client was a lot of the travel industry
right now or what if where your clients were but
then what if you weren't busy then you also you ha
you have a plastic company and they're needing
a lot of things so it just it just all depends
where your position in the market changes so you
just have to be what's this thing uh prepare for
the no expect the worst prepare for the best or
vice versa it's one of those things where you
you can't be a fat cat when you you just
kind of like keep going because there will
be lean times and the same thing with films when
films come out like we just released our film uh
we don't know where what the market that's
the toughest thing about filmmaking because
you have a thing that you made you started three
two four ten years ago but when it reached market
is it the right time for this film does this does
this touch a nerve is it is it two years too early
two years too late so it's the same time when
you release a product is it right or not maybe it
catches on later what was that with donnie darko
it wasn't so so hot here in the states it goes
international it comes back it's a five year five
year process it happens with a lot of different
things so so for anyone who's had a short
film or other films I think you'd go back and
focus on that creating because you can't
determine the market but you can prepare
for it I think that's that's the the balance you
have to do have have be prepared for lean times
and that'll be the best way to go about it what
area of business does your production company
focus on well we have a lot of different
directors who have whether it's healthcare
food fashion documentary so so we we covered a lot
of different industries so we we we could tackle
them all so I figured this out because when I
was as me as a director trying to get on into
a production company I wasn't going to get hired
for a comedy spot because my real or my work
isn't comedic I wasn't going to get hired for for
food because I didn't do any food I had I had a
kind of documentary feel those are the different
jobs that I i would get more cinematic so
I thought we will have our company instead
of turning down jobs let's find the best
directors who does food who does cars who
does fashion who does products who does
travel and that's your roster so if you're if
you're a client that needs cinematic images that
need to have your brain or message elevated and
tell a story that's what we do we want to help you
tell your story and that that's our selling point
like bringing cinematic imagery and and production
to to elevate your your brand and your company's
message so it could be wine industry it could be
fashion it so we pretty much tackle it how do
these directors are a fit for your company first
so when we we see that the directors work and
and it it has to be a certain level and certain
sort of voice that they're telling second
I meet with them and if they have a similar
philosophy or personality because we don't want
to work with jerks there's already so many walking
around it's it's hard it's when we want to work
with good people who are focused on and producing
really good work and also are nice and we had this
motto of work hard and be nice of that aspect so
the directors not only have to be talented
they just have to be nice people because
when you're on set and when
you're dealing with clients
who wants a temperamental director or temple
it's like we should be fortunate to be working
for you we we I want to be surrounded people with
that same attitude of like how can we help you
it's not like I mean businesses it's like nothing
you can't take anything for granted every little
every little job every big job it's
a job that should be treated the same
highly valuable just like I remember
neiman marcus I think someone's telling me
the sales training or someone's training that
you treat everyone who walks through the door
the scene someone who could look like their
transient versus someone who has a mink coat
you never know who's who right so that's the
same thing with an email with a call with if your
client base we we're just fortunate to be able
to see if we can help you and that's that's the
type of directors if they have that attitude and
they they they want to put their nose to the grind
and then they do and funny enough a lot of
our directors have a background in photography
similar to me so so they they they're actually
started as photographers too so it's nice to have
it's just sort of that I know visually that
they they could capture what they they want
they could they could either act as their own
dp or work with dps or and things like that so
funny enough a lot of our
directors are shooters themselves
and what's interesting is too sometimes just
like you said the mink coat versus the transient
analogy sometimes in la the mink coat the more
show the less someone actually yeah that's the
weird part about being here and maybe that's the
same in new york city too but like a lot of times
that's just a front it's not real exactly and
and and you just and you just never know and so
so we those are the type of directors or or
graphic designers or animators or people we
want to work with even in our crew and and things
like that I know it starts they always say it
starts from the top and hopefully we could create
a culture that that is professional but also um
creates that atmosphere where your voice
is heard no one's above anyone else
everyone's open to suggestions and and and
that one's artistic but we don't need to be
van gogh here and be all crazy if you don't get
your way what are your day-to-day duties with your
company maybe pre-covered now during covid so you
get up you fire up that laptop or desktop and then
you go through your emails a lot right now let's
let's talk since it's really right now covid is
research a lot of research that's going on in
terms of uh new clients that we want to kind
of work with we're in a new industry a we have a a
new industry that we're trying to penetrate is the
the golf and luxury resort industry prior to covid
we've got a great couple great directors who who
do that so we're trying to match match match that
up now that's the commercial side but for the film
the film side is we have a couple I have a couple
different films in the in development right now
and one one is we're developing the script or just
shaping it up to be to go out for attachments and
things like that so the last couple of months I've
been trying to get that script right and then and
then and then also we're also producing this
feature film for yifki she's a dutch filmmaker
it'll be her first feature film she her her short
film lily has been screened over 50 film festivals
around the world it's a me too horror film and
her and phosphor is one of her first feature film
we're fortunate enough to be producing that so
we're trying to get things lined up for that as
well so like we were talking about before there's
still a lot of things that could be done even
though we're not everyone's getting used to zoom
and all this stuff but it's it's laying laying
the seeds and and and getting that all done so
that takes most of the day and also preparing for
we just released the film like two weeks or
two september 25th last month and then so
we're we're still pushing that as well so a lot
lots of little different things on on our plate
and so maybe pre-coven was it responding and and
and and post covet or during covet is now hunting
doing research yeah hunting doing research and and
because because you don't know who's going to be
left standing it's a weird thing even while
we were talking with our sales agent who who
we've released our film for north america but
we're still entertaining international territories
like germany uk ireland and all these other
parts but but because of the pandemic of things
different companies have gone under who's staying
so it's almost like everyone's waiting to see
what's what's left who's standing where's the
so they're everyone's adjusting and it's it
and so you kind of have to take a optimistic point
and and and do your research and and tread water
until there's a break yeah it's a it's
very interesting well I mean for commercial
commercial work we used to we had a lot of
shoots postponed cancel and things like that so
you you do you deal with the blows and you
you take it take it with a chin but you
you guys still stand up and prepare as as
when things open up what have you found is
the best way to make money as a filmmaker get
involved in anything that's possible that will
help you get better as a filmmaker whether it's
editing peeing writing on shoot taking any job
any job because that helps you as a writer be a
security guard be a bus driver be on amazon prime
delivery because you're building different
experiences and you could write about that
and still have a living and there's only until you
reach that kind of threshold where you can make
a sustainable career with with with your art or
with your filmmaking but when you're starting out
you take as many jobs as you can teach if you can
teaching helps any any kind of thing so I think
you just have to hustle hustle find any job
survive pay the bills and that if you
can do that that actually teaches you
how to get a film made because it's not getting a
filmmaker is the exact same way because it's not
easy you have to use every little ounce of your
creativity your your experience your inexperience
just combine it on and will will it will it
to happen so if you have to uber drive for two
months so you could write for two months you have
to make those sacrifices what was one of your best
part-time jobs that really helped you actually be
creative and then maybe what was one of your worst
being being a I always said the two things
that made me become a better photographer
not a filmmaker photographer was being a
waiter and being a wedding photographer
you see people at their worst it's like if you
can handle that if you can handle the pressure
of those things that that would help I think
it's it's it's like because what happens plan
a never works I was playing b c and d so if you
could get that in your your your dna and your
bloodline to always have plan d ready that's what
I found filmmaking is about is adjusting adjusting
so the job that I learned was because
how to read folks read people if
if they're happy with the food or not food or
if they don't want you to come near their table
those are those are great instincts
to learn so when you're making a film
are you giving the actors enough space or do you
think does this person need more direction this
person doesn't need any direction you have to know
each does this crew member need that do we need
to sit down so each one you have to read people
differently and under stress stress is caused by
lack of time and lack of money so that's
what happens in filmmaking so people get
it's like bees running around like
ah so if that's gonna happen and
and immediately find the solutions so
they say never let them see you sweat but
I try not to let people see me all
riled up but I'm also crying in the
inside and I just I'm just smiling through
but but being a waiter helped me doing that
you will learn to think on your feet yeah
any customers any kind of customer service
thing your second part of the question what
what job that I didn't like or yeah well I mean
what was maybe and maybe they're the same ones
that that was the toughest because I was wondering
what was one that actually helped your creativity
which sounds like learning how to read people yeah
the other two yep it's being empathetic that's why
any job that could could get you feeling what the
other person is going through the more you can
do that I think that will help with your writing
they'll help with your direction you your
producing skills because once you kind of could
train yourself to walk in other people's shoes you
gain empathy different perspective and then you
you gain an understanding it might not always be
the right understanding but you gain a different
perspective so you don't be so narrow-minded on
your particular review and I think that start
then that that breeds creativity that's the spark
that kind of whoa now I could create this because
this person feels that way you you try to get
all that energy and form something yeah yeah and
maybe to learning how to de-escalate a situation
and so whether you're working in food service
or at someone's wedding or supermarket there's
going to be people that either going to try
to test you or they're really angry and just
learning how to de-escalate before the blow up
exactly I think I think that's it that's a it's
a it's a skill I i was a portrait photographer
and to get someone to trust you to to
relax to to get you to do what you want
or them what how how do you get a sitter to to
to give you a pose that you like it took a lot
of time it's it it deals with trust and how do you
gain that is like giving something from yourself
to to the sitter you can't always take take take
so that I take that on with me working with people
with with the crew we talked about how can I help
how can we help you what could I tell myself that
will make me vulnerable and for you to for for
us to gain that trust and that respect because
I think that that is that's important
that's important that's important
just important way to treat treat your neighbor
this is with respect and you want to understand
how what their life's about and I like that
giving of yourself while you're on set so if
you have an actor that maybe they can deliver but
maybe for whatever reason it's a tense situation
and you're not sure why I mean was it another
person we interviewed talked about sets being
pressure cookers and sometimes there's
personalities on sets whatever it's just
getting that person to feel comfortable I like
that giving yeah and that's and and that takes
it's like chess it's like two three you have
to think like two or three steps ahead like
and I hate to say it's like
almost knowing the situation
and how to diffuse it or manipulate it and
calm things down if you want someone riled up
what would get someone riled up if you
need that reaction if you want someone
in shock like this this is an interesting story I
forget who the photographer was but they had to do
like a shoot of let's say I think it was like
the queen of england or something like that right
and then they're like oh she always gives the
same look how you want something different so
they were shooting at the end was like oh she
she knew like the queen was like a dog lover or
something at the end was like oh how how how was
your ride here and she said it was great until
we ran over a dog and then it clicked and then so
it all these stories and when I was younger I was
naive to think like photography is the truth but
no there's three truths your truth my truth and
the truth so if I wanted you to to pose a certain
way if I want to light you in a certain way
the city would never know it's so it's
so odd to me to to that power later
like oh you could kind of manipulate light and
story differently so I try to hold that kind of
that kind of like knowledge kind of precious
in terms of like understanding and and one
like if we're on the same page and the scene is
about pain how how do we go there and you need
some extra help on that that's where I
think I could come in and maybe help and go
let's talk that out or maybe we don't need to talk
about that out just feel it just let it rip so
each actor is totally different the same
with working with a dp you gotta trust
each other that's why it's fun being a director
you hire you work with people because they know
what they're doing you just get out of the way
and maybe just like could you try it this way
and they're like okay it's it's easy now it's
it's like for me I i I because everyone who you're
working with you I trust them to just do their
what they're there to do and and that's the best
part I think that's where magic happens and just
going back to when you talked about working at
weddings yeah and and they can be pressure cookers
too sometimes it's not actually the bride that's
the problem it's the family oh yeah it's the
family did you make sure did you get that oh were
your wedding photography because I got that same
thing this uncle was like I've worked yeah like
well I i got about 300 photos of them twirling
you need another one yeah I got but again
it's the client and clients are always
right you gotta like suck it up but
I did 14 weddings and that was enough that was
enough for me and I knew that's that skill set is
totally different it's it's definitely great and
there's some great wedding photographers out there
I think I got a glimpse of it and remember I
told you I was a quitter I quit all the time I
quit when photography yeah when did
it was right was it the last one
when I had anxiety and going I don't want to do
this anymore so I think when you have that feeling
of like like I think it's like I made a point
if I and if it felt off I'm gonna try my best
not to feel that bad even if I have to get
another job and become a floral assistant
whatever it is I didn't mind going backwards
because I didn't think it was going backwards
I think it was safety in terms of I want to
get used to to being where where I want to be
I didn't know where I wanted to be I knew I
didn't want to be that remember we talked about
like I knew what I didn't want to do and I
didn't want no I i want to be a filmmaker
and that was like only until I was 35 years
old I didn't know that's that's that's the
path so so when I would quit when when it didn't
feel right and for too long I just didn't want to
waste a year or two years being somewhere I didn't
want to be no weddings are tough for almost like
high school reunions there's a lot of ego and
sometimes it's not coming from the writing room
yeah yeah and and and there's certain there's
only a certain amount of I'll be in a church and
the photographer is not allowed to use
their flash but everyone else is allowed
to use their flag and I'm like oh I can't eat
it so but that's minor I enjoy I value the 14
weddings it gave me that learn how to deal with
pressure and because you've missed the moment
you don't go back to another I do hey can we
take two let's let's take let's do another
take and like that was it sir so if you get
used to that pressure and the pressure to
it's okay if you do fail because what's the worst
thing for me the worst thing in life is to die so
if when I if it's not going to kill me I could
survive it I might not pay rent the next month
but I could survive so that that would I
just tricked my brain to to do weird things
dan can we talk about your life as a daydreamer I
understand that daydreaming is very important to
your creative process what's daydreaming like for
you when you were a kid and what is it like for
you now I don't know I always thought you grow
up and you get in trouble for daydreaming and
things like that and but sometimes you just
can't help but stare outside the window and
and let your let your mind go and I remember
as a kid I don't know if you do it you just do
it everyone daydreams until the they they're told
not to I think and I think I wish we could nourish
that more and and and nor and I think there's a
lot that could be harnessed through that I think
I think that was always a maybe a joke or a
thought that maybe I could become a professional
daydreamer and things like that but I think now
in terms of like how I apply it I i apply it as a
way to maybe my own way of meditating or my own
way of trying to find solutions and ideas and
and and maybe my own way of being in the moment
or in the present so I i find daydreaming
a really useful tool for me in terms of creating
I know it sounds kind of weird it's they're stupid
but it's like it it helps if I'm having like
a if I see or hear things and it could lead to
different things so I could just kind of tune
out and focus on that specific thought or that
specific noise or sound and it could take
me to different places I don't sound so like
weird but it's it's it's relaxing where have
you done some of your best day dreaming can
you do it let's say at a coffee shop you
could do it I think I i think yeah I think
you could you could do it anywhere you could
do it practically not while you're driving
but you but but if you're just sitting sitting
by outside sitting at a park sitting by yourself
that you just take a moment and and you
think of think think of thoughts think
think of ideas and let that like let that
kind of permeate and and and last blossom
it could be even the thought of hawaii just the
word hawaii then it starts then you could focus
on the the sound of it the vials and and what
that takes you there's just different connections
that you can make so then it could take you to
coffee to pineapple to to different things and
then your brain is visualizing these these image
these images and then I think once you kind of
get get used to doing that for me I do
it just because I i get lost in thought
because something might it might be my head
and then it takes me somewhere and I find that
useful and is daydreaming the same
as meditation or they're different
they're probably in the same world and it's
linguistics of it of it on if you are meditating
and focusing but but I think daydreaming is
cool is because you could set ideas you could
set things and in your head and and you could
you could try to implement those if you could
remember it it's it's I guess it's it's the
opposite when you dream at night right when you're
dreaming at night and we have all these dreams
that pop up of things all of a sudden you might
have a dream like hey why is that guy in my third
grade class in my dream it just pops up right
and then when you're daydreaming you're like the
same thing I was like oh but it seems like you're
you're conscious of that I think that opens up
opens up your your your creative space to accept
ideas and they go oh like when I get stuck writing
I guess that's why people hey go for you go for
a walk you go this you how does the ending really
work how do these subplots come together how does
that and then people say they fi have ideas in
the shower or these things these moments I think
those are important having those moments I think
it starts with a little bit of daydreaming because
once you focus too much it's like you're
not seeing the possibilities with that's
like behind you or beside you you're so narrow
you're narrowed into the script this story but
if you let go and start thinking about the
cup that's on the table of your character
and how that cup reminds you of your grandmother's
cup and then a grammar when she was born here
and then that leads to this oh she used to love
this flower that was purple maybe that flower
ends up somehow back in your
scripts you just never know
so it's it's making associations with things
that that sometimes don't don't connect
immediately so I think that's what helps me
so so I think that's a great tool especially
writing but then you have to there's all these
things you have to find a thread otherwise they
just become images it's both story you need
you need that thread so that's the other thing
now is to pull all that dreaming together and
have it structured and that's the that's the
battle of screenwriting did you used to get in
trouble in school for daydreaming with teachers
i might have got to you and
use of time wisely I think
so the unsatisfactory thing so I think that I
might have gotten that but I always try to avoid
getting in trouble but doesn't mean
you can't be sneaky and and they dream
well no one's looking so yeah if you were going
to teach a class on daydreaming let's suppose
the the idea of daydreaming has changed
and now it's more reinforced let's suppose
they take from different people einstein
different just and you put it in together into
a course what would what would day one be like
in your daydreaming course yeah day one I would
just introduce the thought of it and talk about
what will what we would do during this this term
and kind of structure it and go like and and and
and tell folks that what is the goal what's our
goal with this there's science there is technology
there's things but there's also this thing called
mystery so to offer and that's where the beauty
of new innovation comes from I think so I was
first talk about what they get everyone's opinion
what daydreaming is I i there isn't a specific
answer that's how you feel but then talk about
how we were just so bombarded by visuals and and
especially nowadays and and not understanding what
the visual language is well how do we why do we
feel certain things when we see certain type
of imagery maybe getting the same page and
and say the first third of our course would be
understanding a visual language what does that
mean when we drive down sunset boulevard why do
why do all these colors why what does yellow and
and purple due to us versus gray and pink and
these things so so that helps so then when you're
able to understand that then maybe you could
start to visualize and that's part of daydreaming
daydreaming you want to be a filmmaker what does
that entail I didn't know but in definitely until
getting off the couch let me start with that
and then definitely until maybe I should go to
half-price books and buy a book maybe what's the
story you think about story and and then you you
think about themes and then that could lead
lead somewhere so yeah well first third of class
course talk about visualization
how do we interpret visual language
second third is to apply that to let's let's let's
work on our thoughts and our way to daydream and
recollect those things and how that could help and
how long could he do it in 30 seconds 30 minutes
whatever and then the last third of the
course would just to be to understand what
what we did what's the goal of it and was it
successful how could we use this in future
applications of creative work that's that's what
maybe the first class would be like you mentioned
mystery does mystery always having having
a does mystery always have to be let's say
solving a crime or figuring something out
in science could it also be figuring out a
character doesn't even have to be some criminal
or scientific element it's just figuring out
who they are why they did something why they said
something like exactly I think so it encompasses
so much and I think it's it's like I think I
think that's what's fantastic about it because it
it it incorporates the unknown and incorporates
things that we maybe have on the tip of our
tongue and we want to explore and understand it we
want to solve things we're driven by a mystery we
that takes us to new places I think that's
what's what's really neat and dynamic of
understanding how to how to
use mystery in your own work
to tell stories to create suspense to to and then
to have resolution because because we need I think
us humans we need closure and and understanding
but we also don't need to be handheld at least
at least for stories some folks might but for me
as a as a storyteller I'm not I i always think
the audience is smarter than definitely smarter
than me and and you don't want to treat them
too like hand holding everything so you
want to leave things to interpretation
but I also don't want to be so abstract that
no one understands what the story is about
so so those are two different things I'm battling
with right now and mystery is a a good way to
to keep me inspired and and and work my way
through through life trying to figure things
out what's what's an example of a handheld story
from a writer versus something that's too abstract
okay I guess every probably david lynch is
is that is there and a handhold would be
more of two plus two equals four that
that boy meets girl they fall in love
versus boy meets girl for other things
could happen things like that so you as
a as the storyteller it's I always think it's like
on being a chef right we have these ingredients
and and the way you use it whether it's where
where the where it hits you it's how you use
these elements of story to do it you want to
hand hold someone from the end and go this
person is definitely the killer or this person is
definitely the bad bad guy who planted the seed
who's trying to get them to break up and remarry
her or things like that so it's up to up to each
chef and and the audience is so vast and diverse
like a lot of people are definitely not gonna like
some of the dishes I cook because it's it's
not their flavor on profile but does that mean
you could deny the execution of it or
the craft of it it's like if you don't
like country music but you like indie rock
you cannot deny johnny cash was a skilled
and talented musician it's just a taste so that's
what happens I think in terms of what how you tell
stories and hand holding is a great great device
but for me as as a chef I i don't want to add
too much salt kind of like as things goes I'll
leave it to the audience a little bit more to
piece the flavors together do you think that
people look at daydreaming in a positive way
that's a tricky question I was going to say yes
but then I'm gonna say no because everyone will
be talking about it more and how is that because
it's it has more of a negative connotation because
it means you don't get anything done maybe if
we re rewrite that narrative in terms of day
dreaming as a step to execution into work
where you're daydreaming of being a making
great leather purses then you that happened
where you're daydreaming of solving
going to the space these things it starts
with some sort of idea planted in a
a world that seems so far away but if you you
set it and you do the work it could be attainable
I'm not saying it all is hap can happen but
at least it gives you hope that an idea can be
reached tried tried for so I think when if you
ask parents maybe they don't think it's a good
good thing if their kids are always daydreaming
but I i I hope they it it changes because
I love that word I love the word dream it's it's
it's it's that means we are an ideas thought out
of and it could be possible but we have to
sometimes enjoy that process of making it
possible in the result the result of that dream
so that's the tricky part tricky part how does
daydreaming help us reach our goals daydreaming
it helps you start with an idea it helps you
be open and I think that is and it's in
itself a success if you are able to open
and accept new ideas and think of things that are
possible that that helps because we need goals how
does daydream get us there it gives us a shovel
they give us a tool it gives us things that we
we maybe feel like we we can't accomplish and
we might make an an excuse hey I can't get this
degree because I don't have money but you could
start by daydreaming and if you if that daydream
makes you become obsessive makes you become
passionate makes you become driven then that
that's helpful but if that daydream turns
into a nightmare then it could lead you to
another daydream so that's where I think it's
it's useful because there's many many chances
many doors out there where that can open
daydreaming allows you to hop hop around
and then when you want to sit on something then
that sets a path to your goals do you ever give
yourself a limit though for daydreaming like
okay I've daydreamed at least an hour today and
I think I've reached my limit now I'm going to get
back to something that's more linear yeah yeah I
well no I don't think I do it subconsciously I
think I think it happens that's why I think it's
a little bit different than meditation because
you designate a certain time maybe I do it so
much that I don't even know I could be washing the
dishes and then though I'm washing the dishes and
get getting it done I have just I just went to
ethiopia and the ethiopia just opened up this new
type of bread that I wouldn't want to discover
while I'm washing dishes it's so I don't think
you could do enough maybe I'll go there I'll go
the opposite I was like until it hinders your goal
i think you need to keep exercising that muscle
just like walking or breathing or doing things
and if it helps you reach goals then it's useful
if it doesn't that means it's it's it's an excuse
and that's a fine line I think that to walk so
and that's the practice and that's going to be
everyone's journey to to to go hey I've been
daydreaming that's why I don't I'm not getting
anywhere I've been daydreaming oh that's
why I'm here so it's that it's it's that
half glass half full half empty kind of thing
so it's going to be up to each individual
to kind of figure out if it's it's if it's for
them or there or if they're doing it too much
you mentioned you liked the writer charles
bukowski and I have a quote here from his
1989 book hollywood and I'll change the
wording a little bit just to clean it up but
I believe he said people became so used to
seeing crap on film that they no longer realized
it was crap do you feel that way about movies
today easy he's a straight shooter isn't he so
it's funny after after completing
my film first feature and
it's such a miracle to create anything
to get anything done I'm very bad bad at
critiquing or criticizing because what
whether it's crap or or or oscar-worthy or
just magnificent that's again up to the
audience as a creator all you can do
is is hope that you you got out what was inside
out there for for me and movies that are hey
this is this one not not better than the other
I see enjoying mom because if you if it's just
someone's sweat and tears that went through it
I i tend to look at that more of it and I'm so
sorry to disappoint on charles but I don't kind of
I'm not that controversial to say that it's crap
I don't have that I don't think I have
that authority because I make a lot of crap
it goes back to two what you're talking
about hand-holding the audience versus
being too abstract would you say a lot
of tentpole movies are hand-holding and
maybe some people want that yeah yeah and that
that that's the taste and I remember I don't know
if I was in school or someone said hey if you want
to make a lot of money shoot for the middle so
but it there's a place where every everything I
always I was I was thinking about that that funny
thing about 10 of us like black licorice and why
why does black licorice hang around all the time
because but if I could ever have a career like
black licorice I'll be very happy I don't have
to please everyone just sometimes your work isn't
for everyone but sometimes you want to go for that
joyride you can't watch a million dollar baby
three times in a row and it's like it's great
but it's brutal but maybe you just want to go for
a joyride and and every every medium every art
has has that I can't eat rich tomahawk ribeye or
something like that and it's I'm gonna get gout
and then or every day but I could eat pizza
every day but then there's levels of that so
I know I'm talking a little bit weird and
abstract of it so yes big hollywood films
has a big place because people enjoy it
artsy art house films people enjoy that too
it's just giving people the the opportunity
to see them I think that's more important and
then everyone can whether marketed differently or
what but that's a different different conversation
just to say who's doing what but it just
takes but you think about it like look
at all the films that when when the oscars now
and stuff it's not it's all moonlight parasite
very prestige fair it's so so we need we
need it all I think we need we need it all
do you think each group has their own strong
opinions literary music film and there's just
so many talking heads arguing about what's right
what's wrong yeah I think I think because I think
everyone gets because everyone's passion gets
opinionated and everyone feels strongly about a
a situation maybe because I lived in a
household full of people where I always
had to listen to everyone first and understand
and I've always like tried to be diplomatic in
a lot of different ways and that's helped but now
as you try to get in more firm and more confident
you have you can't always please everyone you
have you you are going to do things for yourself
and sometimes that's going to rub people wrong
so when you have all these people whether it's
in the music that hey so-and-so is this so oh this
is like that this work is too much like the coen
brothers or cone brother stink or blah blah and
that's that's great everyone's entitled to their
opinion and that's the the beauty of discourse
I think what happens is when the vitriol kind
of kind of gets the fire going I think that's
that's that's that's the thing when it becomes
personal but in terms of like each industry I
think everyone should be passionate what they
they root for it's like sports like you got Dallas
cowboy fans versus the steeler fans everyone
likes their thing so you pick your tribe and
you push for it and then just some folks feel
like they need to be missionaries so when you
sit down to write a story do you start with a
treatment or an outline now each each process has
been a little bit different for me for each one uh
i've I've i've done quite a bit of one with
treatments and outlines but they're they're
very useful but what I found more useful is
the the we talked about before the movie days
that's helped me give it give it to give it a
structure but I would come with idea and then and
sometimes it depends on each each script sometimes
I'll let it flow and just kind of I'll have an
ending and I'll have a image and we'll start from
there but then maybe one month later I'll start
an outline because I'm stuck so but I like to be
flexible on that in my routine just depending on
because some stories come out I think it's like
writing I can only imagine if it's like writing
music some some songs you always hear those
great songs whether it's dolly parton doing
something like nine to five in like two minutes
or something like that or like or like someone oh
I just walked into the night and just wrote this
master's piece sometimes it pours out sometimes
it's laborious but again so I i think those are
useful treatments and not online so definitely
that was a great movie too yeah oh nine to five oh
yeah yeah that's great with your film All Roads To
Pearla it started with an idea from seeing a paper
bag or a plastic bag yeah well I had an image
of that I also had an image of the texas landscape
and I had the feeling of this wide open space
at night and and I knew that one of the characters
was a wrestler and during when your
wrestling season I used to wrestle
sometimes you would sleep in a plastic bag and
then I had these images of plastic there's a
plastic bag hanging in a tree sometimes
when you drive around in the desert and
things like that are out out there you'll see
that so it started what with with the landscape
seeing plastic and then having that feel of then
I thought of plastic bag body bags then I thought
which was all because of daydreaming you think you
start your driving your day well I told you not
to drive and daydream but I was on the road a lot
for for my assignments and you're covering texas I
covered like five thousand miles in 21 days to do
like 18 shoots one time and that was how already
superlast sort of coming out is because I saw all
these places and faces and I didn't want that to
end so I would just combine them and create my own
story and were you doing a full loop around texas
the outskirts I did I've probably I've probably
seen more of texas and texans I've been to eagle
pass brownsville on midlands pecos everything
for just all different types of assignments so
and that's that that's why that landscape to me
had so much like mystery so much history and and
it was just like wow this is this is unbelievable
it's like you hear stories of cowboys and this
but to actually see that land it was awesome and
the people and and the culture you can't yeah I
was definitely inspired by by that and then I
did and then I was sent down to houston to do
a story and then that tied in to what I was doing
and in houston there's this two mile stretch
where there are these massage parlors
illegal massage parlors and then I was in
I got to go on a raid with sheriff so I
would I would have all these like interesting
heavy assignments whether it's immigration to that
to exilery the michael morton he was accused of
killing his wife served like 22 years in death
row but later found out that he didn't do it so
all these human interest stories I i wanted to
understand it what that was all about we make
these choices and sometimes those choices aren't
good enough and and then we we have to live with
the consequences good or bad so that's what
happened in my time driving around in texas how
did you feel let's say you get out at a road stop
go to use the bathroom at an older gas station or
you stop for a bite to eat at a cafe I mean
like how was that you're just interacting with
it's interesting being an asian american enjoying
this going around a different like I think I went
to the least populated county once population like
10 or something like that it's cool it's cool it's
it's again I felt like I was like in in in a movie
all the time I felt like it was but it's real it's
awesome it's the people the culture again I
keep talking about that but when I would stop
it's sort of like when you get so used to thinking
what could happen like if these laws could talk
who lived here 20 years ago 40 years ago what
what family it's the same thing what happened this
stop what happened this single single family
home who owned it before so your brain just goes
all over the place and I think working as a
photographer I was able to catch it with one frame
but now as like you you could write you could
write these stories and just make it up like oh
this is what happened fred walked out the door
got hit by a truck his son's out for revenge
there okay now let's have fun and let's spend next
two hours writing about that why who was who hid
in the truck was there a motive what fred do that
other person it's so that's that's kind of neat
and that helps with if you daydream a lot because
then you just go oh what happens over there
well maybe fred had it coming well that's what the
mayor said well the sheriff is a lot don't just
so you can keep going it's fascinating interesting
on being on the road you you I think we're where
we behave differently too if for let's say I took
a greyhound across country one time as a kid and
if you're in your own car versus you're in
waiting in line at an airport or something
you and you just you're seeing all these
people and you're imagining what their
lives are like and they're looking at you
thinking the same thing and it's just I
don't know we're just in a different mindset
I think when we travel even just domestically
yeah when you're seeing like I would walk when I
was in new york or anywhere even here and you walk
by so many people and you're just like I wonder I
wonder what their are we ever going to meet again
then you're like I wonder how many photos I'm
in in the background that that I don't know
of and things like that and you then you realize
how many people are in this world and then you
realize how many stories there are but then
you're like we're all human we have these same
emotions how do we tap on into that and that's
why when you hear music and songs that could move
a whole country a whole world that
is amazing to have write something
in three minutes to have something play in
three minutes and it just moves everyone
yeah Mozart or anything like that Elvis
and and and Beatles so which means we're
connected in a certain way we're connected
with emotions so I think when we travel
though we see different things differently as
different people who are still connected with
those human emotions and things that's that's
what the fun part is as as a creator so I grew up
and if from I'm from Laos my grandmother came to
the states in 1986 she didn't know any english
so and my allow is not great the greatest
so it's for us to communicate was
there's other other ways maybe that's why I like
filmmaking or or photography it was other ways to
communicate there's were like she would I would
try to have to translate general hospital to her
and why luke and laura got married and things like
that in lao and it was funny so when you when you
with another language and you got to find
other ways to communicate maybe that I got
so into visuals into into sounds so those
are things that could express things versus
literally I am sad I'm telling you I'm sad versus
like a frown so that kind of stuff so it's it's
it's neat is it important for you to know the
ending before you start writing your screenplays
I mean I would love to I would love to know the
inning all the time it'll be awesome sometimes I
have it and sometimes it changes I would love
to know as many parts of the puzzle as I can
sometimes you discover it and it goes
another way and I think that's the beauty of
of sitting down and chipping things
away because it might make more sense
a lot of times it anchors things and having an
ending where you're concrete about it helps and so
but then you might fall in love with the
characters and you don't want you don't want
it to end that way so again trying to be flexible
with that is good in my opinion but having it
knowing the ending would be awesome and sometimes
I i have that in my head and then and then you you
play around with the themes and then you follow
the themes and hopefully you could direct direct
everything towards the end so that would be my
process I don't know it works all the time but
as a rule that sounds like you don't always have
to to know the ending before you begin something
yeah I think so I think so it would be very
helpful and it will just guide and help guide but
I think you have a gist of your story and then if
you have that just then you probably could get to
the ending quicker than you if you don't have
that with All Roads To Pearla did the ending
as you begin
i had an idea of an ending now knowing
how to tie it all up it took me a while
I remember I did have like
I know how I wanted to end
but how it what but how how it ended was still up
in the air because there were so many loose parts
I think one of the things that I found
even with the script in the early stages
is I don't know if anyone out there has a similar
problem your story lines sometimes it has to
you got to wrangle them back and and have that
fit on it and that that was the trick tricky part
and not make it seem so forced and things and
massage it correctly and and get still get your
message across or what the story's about so yeah
when I started I had an idea what's gonna happen
but without giving anything away it it it was
it guided but the little details was harder
maybe help me understand that so is it
almost like if you're gonna search for
halloween decorations but then you go down
this rabbit hole and now you're searching
fall you're going and then you're like what
wait my original plan was to look for halloween
decorations is that so we're talking about
where you go you have to wrangle it back in
yeah like like let's say for instance I had we had
skeletons we had zombies and we had we have ghosts
but only the ghost is at the end what happened
to the skeleton and the zombies without it
becoming did we forget him at the aisle 14
or like or did it or did they disappear or
did the ghost take it so if you knew
that the ghost is the one that's there
at the end because you just you don't you in
the front yard then maybe you want the zombies
in the back later you know you have the elements
but you thought like you wanted the ghost to be
the one that is the main highlight I think
that's what I'm kind of talking about more
like I have an idea I want the ghost to be my
the guy out there but how do I what I do with
the rest of the crew I mean that interesting
okay and and do do we really need to know
how much and why you've left the skeleton in
the aisle 4 or 14 whatever that goes back to
our discussion of do you want to hand hold more
or do you want to leave it leave it on leave it
leave it a little bit more obscure so do we
leave a foot out then you see the skeleton foot
in aisle 14 or do you want the entire leg out or
do you want the entire body out so you could see
that he that skeleton got killed at aisle 14 that
kind of stuff so that's the that's what's I think
what I'm talking about in terms of like have an
ending I have a feeling ending how do I get there
with all these other other things that are
happening but then sometimes you go what
actually the skeleton should be the one
that's at the end that so that could happen
but with all rose and perrla I had it I had
a feeling what I wanted my challenge was like
I know I knew the last page my challenge
was the five pages prior to that last page
that kind of thing of tying things up and
getting it right and who's and how do we
get there to make it kind of dramatic and
suspenseful things like that and how long
did it take you to write the full script the
first draft I started it like 10 10 years ago
the first maybe a good good draft afterwards maybe
like eight months eight months or so and then
rewrite rewrite rewrite more of of it so I can't
even remember now it's like so so so kind of like
long ago but I do remember when I was starting
it because I was like I'm gonna try to write
my I wrote one feature I was like I'm gonna do
this this one and then I got stuck and I took
one character and wrote a short film on it and
that short film became my first short film called
balloons go pop of it so I i used it as a a way to
kind of like have a sort of like a sounding board
I i didn't have the pressure of like oh I need to
finish it in six months or nine months I was just
going through exercises of it and trying to figure
my way out even dialogue even all the all the
elements of screenwriting so I was trying to just
get better at it and then that over time I went
back to the story and shaped it up until I felt
confident that there was something there and that
was a 10-year process from script to screen from
script to final shooting draft probably six five
five six years yeah
okay so you knew at that point then
this is something I'm committed to
if this story still interests me that many
years later I think so if you ask my wife
and I think I was so stupid I was like hey
if I die could you make this film please
it's so dumb I don't know I just got so like I
don't know I i don't even know why it's just like
I just wanted to finish I i just wanted
to finish it because it took so much to
get it going and then I just didn't want
it to sit in my drawer or sit in my laptop
so I i I enjoyed the characters and I just
wanted to kind of see it come alive and again
that's a selfish thing to oh I wrote something
I wanted to see it come alive that kind of thing
and and and that's what I was driven at
because like I said I love to quit things when
when when it doesn't feel right and this never
not felt right so I just kept going and going
and even though there are multiple many moments of
of it's brutal it's so it's a brutal thing and I
i want to kind of and not say there's a myth
of of things there's a brutal stretch of each
of each of the process to get it done how what
are you doing with your life how's this happening
how's the finance going how are you going to make
grant where are you going to do this how what if
you don't get to this festival what does this
distribute all these kinds of weird things that
you don't think about when you first start
writing and going oh fade in you don't think
then we're like oh it just leads you on so the
journey has been quite quite interesting and but
sometimes when you see these things you all see
some person awesome they have a movie and austin
they get another movie and all this and it just so
happens because I was there and going how did this
happen I was like but my thought was if someone
else can do it let me deconstruct this I could
figure this out and do it so my only thing is just
trying to figure it out how to do it so it's like
I found one side of the rubik's cube that's
that's what happened and here we are just ready
sadistically enough ready to try to do another
one so there you have it is it really that selfish
though to want to make it I mean going back to
we talked about it's also selfish to want to be
promoted in corporate america so yeah it's really
selfish maybe that's me just kind of like make me
feel better because because in the end it is a
lot of like trying to play to your ego play ego
your own ego and and and figuring out and and
going why do you want to do this I cuz I think
it's a very honest question to ask yourself
in the mirror why do you want to do this um
it's almost because that's all you kind of want
to do and maybe feel like you're somewhat good at
not because if someone's telling you that you're
good at it is because you feel that it feels like
you're good at it it's it's hard because it's
like people try you try to enter competitions
and you try to do this and get validated
and serve in different ways I think I got so
rejected so many times that I i didn't want I was
like screw validation I love doing it I'm going
to keep doing it it's like but what was that what
does that entail and when is it when is it enough
so I'm still trying to figure that out as I go and
one isn't enough when do do I have to write how
many scripts do I have to write how many movies
that would would I will make me happy so then
I'll be like hmm it's again just trying to make
a sustainable career that's just to go my goal
so that's where I am at this point and and trying
to sometimes it's a curse because you're like
you wish I i wish I would have gotten for
that that fourth more rejection to go okay
now I'm becoming a marketing assistant or
something like that and you're like ah that
would be so much easier gosh but now you're just
like why am I cursed to kind of put myself in
people I love in this this kind of like brutal
kind of journey of filmmaking but then it's a
privilege situation to cry about creating so
being off camera as we were taking a quick break
you said something about possibly why why not just
do this as a hobby filmmaking screenwriting yeah
yeah I know you know I ask myself that every day
it's like sometimes it's it's it's just easier or
more precious when you keep something to yourself
as a hobby it's like this going at it and going
making it a living it's it's not all 100 being
creative it's like it's 85 business 15 being
creative and and you have to be okay with that
sometimes and that and that is the the trick
that that could lead to that cynicism and like
and and and things that that happened so what
so I asked huh I should just keep writing because
I enjoy it but what's that need what's that need
so yeah I asked myself that every day sometimes I
wish it was a hobby but I'm too stubborn and too
crazy to that lets sleeping a sleeping dog lie
or something like that so I keep pushing ahead
can you describe your typical writing day yeah
so I said I i find that I get a lot of good stuff
down earlier my brain just is more lucid I think
because it's it maybe is because I'm
coming off of like a sleep so six
seven six seven to nine a.m is where I think I
write my write my best that's me personally and
I'll just tackle tackle that and
try to write some days I some days
I could get four pages some days I'll get half
a page but when I'm finishing up a script um
i write till like two or three from that
more so try to get a good eight hour
get eight hours and sometimes I'll stare at the
page or I'm researching or on on talking things
out or writing at but when I'm finished working
on a script I i I try to do that a good amount
like good study mount each day the rewrites when
I'm doing rewrites so after just recently we are
we just did a read through so we'll have it read
through to see how it sounds because sometimes
when you read a script you read it faster or
slower so when you have someone who just reads it
out you can get a better time if it's the scenes
too long if everyone's twitting their thumb and
going like hey let's wrap this up that's when we
you could tell we want to cut it cut it up more
make it faster so we'll do a read through and then
we'll have notes and then I'll go through wake up
and send some emails but then I'll go through
the notes and and and knock knock it out and
go hey this we need to add a little more humor
here or hey we got to do this or cut this out or
this is a three-page scene we need to trim
it down so I would work those angles so
again the earlier the better for me so I could
it doesn't seem like my brain works a little bit
better that way when you do the read through or
you have someone else do it are they reading with
no emotion yeah they're just reading it through
so they don't have to act it out they could just
read scene headings seeing this and sometimes
they they'll get into an act but they don't have
to be it doesn't have to be like a table read of
everything but just go interior jacob's kitchen
so and so it comes in then and they're
they'll just read it normal yeah so so
we could see the pacing and then if there's
a issue where they want to go it's like hey
does he really have does he really say yes
ma'am right now he said it three yes ma'am
three three three pages ago or something I don't
think he's going to say yes ma'am now so you could
really kind of work on dialogue too and that
it just sounds a little bit off or forced so it
every everyone would have like an idea and
me as a writer I'll take the notes and go
and that helps that helps because when
you when you guys are reading in your head
sometimes you get stuck so it's nice
to kind of hear it hear the words out
it doesn't have to be acted out but the but
that'll give you a better time frame so I
recommend that if you get even a friend after you
finish something having to read through it took
the last read through it took us about we started
11 and finished at like four because you're going
through each word each page each word leave a stop
and go oh what do you think about that things like
that so that really helped there's a new new
job description in the pandemic yeah yeah have
a job as a reader yeah just read it through on
zoom or something yeah absolutely nice because
it's better to have someone versus a writer
read it or director so you could sit there have
your team of collaborators a producer director
whoever and so they could hear it and hear it out
once you start writing a screenplay how often do
you write how often do you go to write it so page
one of something you're getting up at six in the
morning maybe you're excited and then maybe you're
stopping at 9am depending on your schedule
and then how often are you going back to it
during the day during the course of however long
it takes you to finish so whether it's a year
10 years I just did I just finished
one it took me about four months and I
spent every day pretty much at it for about
average of like four to five hours a day on it so
that one yeah so it depends like I said the
always the Pearla look how long it took but
now as you get better and you're more confident
of of of what you want and the structure of the
scenes and things like that and I had in my
head of like what Stephen King always says
of like you don't wait for inspiration you just
get to work so even if I'm staring at the page
or something I'm zoned in I'm i'm focusing on it
so I i wanted to kind of just keep chiseling it
and and sometimes you get great breakthroughs
and you'll write a good amount but
it's different for each one for the last couple
months I'll be disciplined on that like I just try
to treat myself like a like an athlete if I had
to go do this for if in a day what would so and
so I hear let's say like I just read something
that was just on jimmy butler from Miami he
gets he said he was up at three or four a.m
practicing or something like that so I wanted
to implement those kind of like practices they
always say like I i try to do things that that
that you don't want to do because they're
usually good for you and then so it's like
I don't want to wake up every day and do this but
but if you love it and if you're challenged by it
it's it's not that painful so I'm fortunate to
kind of go oh awesome I'm gonna work on on this
meanwhile we're also trying to run commercials
and things like that so you have to balance
kind of different things and stuff and
and doing that and you might not have
certain weeks where you can but I'll try at
least slide something in maybe in it maybe it's
2 a.m to 4 4 afterwards but at least I'll try
to put the hours in for for writing yeah well
so you're up writing occasionally at 2 a.m yeah
sometimes yeah sometimes yeah because you're like
you're just so you're just so kind of
addicted to it because like you're in the cut
if you're just in the cusp of breaking through
the scene and just get it out and then you can
come back later and elevate it and and
just and texturize it and do this but
but you're in a role like if you keep getting
rolls then you'll get to that 90 page 100 page
and you're like ah I'm finished and let it sit
and now you could work on the rewrite afterwards
does writing energize you or exhaust you
both they they just kind of like hit you and
I get really excited when I could create that
world that gets me really excited when I get
the characters alive it exhausts me because I want
it to go faster than than what where it's going I
you want it sounds like christmas you want
christmas to come right away you want to just tear
through the presents but it's and and you you come
in on all sorts of problems and you just wish that
you could figure it out right away and sometimes
you need that break though it's like how come I
didn't think about it yesterday but today is
so clear this is what has to happen and and
that that's exciting when I get that it's
frustrating when I couldn't think about it
that day the answer to that that question oh
like oh that's a great line that leads to this
or or maybe I should add this action to it so it
does energize me but it's definitely frustrating
what is the most difficult part of the writing
process for you yeah I like to always try to be
like honest of of the the ability of what I can
do and you strive to be the best you can and like
I think the most difficult part is
because you want it to be so good
you're trying to figure out ways and there's so
many elements to that is it this it's the story
it's the dialogue it's it's the characters and how
that all fits in it's putting it all together it's
the difficult part is to make each scene so good
that there is no bad scene so if there is a bad
scene you have to get that scene out so that
how do we get it everything's so good that's
and that's the tough that's that's what we're
all trying to figure out right how do we get the
reader to turn the page to keep turning the page
it's when it gets boring when it's when only gets
not interesting when there's not a voice when
the characters are doing the same thing we've
seen this it's so so it's hard to find that
creativity that juice to kind of you might
have one great scene but then the other three
are like average how do I get those other three
from a three to a five how do I get get it
to a five and that's the frustrating part
like dang is it the story or dang is it the
character itself or is it my stupid dialogue
it's like that's the heart the hardest part of
it all the frustrating part and that's what keeps
you going because you got one good scene it keeps
you're asking about what energizes oh man that was
great it felt good it was gone then then the next
scene it comes to the dead hold and like stop and
like what did I just write it makes no sense it's
boring it's it's cliche it's now or never it's I
love you versus it's easy to say like show it show
it on screen show the thing but to actually do it
is that's the craft and beauty of what all these
great screenwriters are trying to do and it's like
you see michael jordan shooting the basketball but
you don't see him all those years of practice so
so we just try to get to work and craft the
scene as best as we can and get better at it
and and then finish the story and hop on into the
next one did you watch last dance I did yeah yeah
that's nice it's really fascinating yeah
behind I always yeah I love seeing everyone's
process of of how to do things right right
especially someone who's very tenacious and
always wants to and knows that that's something
in him that he almost can't stop himself yeah
yeah so it's so you could have it you
could have a talent you could have all that
you could have a lot of different things but I
think what's hard to teach is that obsessiveness
why do you want to wake up it's easy to
sleep easy to put it off to the next day so
but because of the pandemic and stuff we
are we're all going through those questions
what like of of of things what's important what
do we want to do what do we want to accomplish
how much time do we have things like that I think
for me it was I i made a decision I mean I lost
my mom through breast cancer 15 years ago so that
was the launch of me going I'm just gonna try it
and and try try something that I don't know what's
gonna happen because it's easy to try things when
what's gonna happen and still so I was like I
think being with her for those last couple months
of just trying to go like and giving her saying
go ahead it was just I was like oh my gosh I could
go ahead and go ahead really you were
I never had that kind of freedom from
a parent her especially her because she wanted me
to do other things but but then she finally knew
and I i loved that I was like I'm going to take
this and run and see how far I could get so that's
that's what kind of helped start it all no so my
sort of pandemic hit 15 years ago of going like oh
we're not giving tomorrow and I I'm gonna try as
hard to get better each day because I like doing
it I'm not gonna waste time I'm not gonna waste a
year if I'm in a job that I didn't like because I
I'm not guaranteed next year I kept that in my
head so that's why I had this thing about time
just because of my mom and so that that helped
me kind of like appreciate time and appreciate
good and bad things it's not to say I
want to have everything being great but
it's just I want to live life I want to
experience it all I just don't want to waste time
being unhappy i'd like to be unhappy because I
could feel I just want to spend two years on it
sometimes I feel like I'm living for two people
so you want to experience everything and you want
it it's it's just as simple as going outside
or taking the trash out so all the things that
I would convince myself I that are hard or
because I'm lazy or I was like even doing
that I should just be grateful for going walking
outside doing this so if I have an opportunity to
write a script that's luxurious so I'm gonna I'm
gonna swing for the fences because not given uh
tomorrow pretty much
with your screenwriting van do you try to be
original or do you try to give the audience
what you think they would want I think I try to
come up the original concept and and you want to
start out with that and because that sort of what
what drives you I know you suppose I know they
say hey think about what what the audience is they
think about your audience what's your genre who's
watching this who's doing that but I think you
just start writing the story that motivates you
and and what gets you through because you're gonna
if you're gonna have to live with this for a long
time in terms of like producing it or in terms of
writing it and then if you go on to try to get it
produced and made it has to be something that
that that you're proud of or that you want to
go through that journey with so if that idea
is an original idea for you and and at least
it's for me I start with that so all the scripts
that I have on written is is is basically from
original thoughts and not I don't even think
about the budget and stuff like that maybe because
the stories I write just tend to fall in the
same thing but it's not super high concept
it's not out in space it's not this it's just like
grounded in what's happening here in humanity but
but when I start out something like
I come it from a original perspective
do you think you could be okay with being a writer
for hire or something where it may not be your
style and maybe two hand-holding of a of a story
but you're being sort of like okay paid to do it
even though it might not be something you would
want to watch would you have trouble with that um
this is like me going through like if I'm
actually writing sticking to the themes
my original thought of all this
was to have a sustainable career
so to answer that yeah I would do it I'm not a
young buck coming out at 25 years old and having
the luxury of a lot of time time and
doing this but I think the more you
can do anything the better you get get at it
you always hear now I start to understand why
people might complain why actors take certain
roles and things like that no one can't everyone
can't be daniel day-lewis and do these maybe you
just want to be a role that's goofy and fun maybe
I want to test my chops on something different
from I'm not we talked about athletes and stuff
you want to come back to each season with new
things that you learn everything whether if
I ever get a chance at a studio world writing
something that's that I'm gonna learn something
from that you could always take that back and then
I could always do it as a hobby my own stuff later
that kind of stuff so things like that I'm still
not opposed to that if if that is an opportunity
or I'm not one of those I'm going to be not
tour and everything that's going to happen
just trying to take it one one film at a time if
it happens they'll be I think that would be um
a good problem to have to make that decision I
always wonder about like actors who get these
commercials where they become these spokespersons
for like well over a decade and and how do they
feel about that I mean if it if it provides
a nice lifestyle for someone and they feel
a sense of satisfaction maybe they weren't the
leading role on general hospital or something but
it was always but then some people go to
the sellout term and I think that would be
I think most of us would probably
they'd go with the steady paycheck yeah
we think percentage-wise of things and me
you want how many like you said how many of
us can can be Paul Thomas Anderson or Quentin
Tarantino how many people are even behind the
scenes doing stuff that we don't even know about
that no one does that has to punch up a script
or do this or do whatever you ha you have but if
you're in it beats other things so like you know
you know definitely it would be something that's
now it's not like something you always want to do
and you want to build leverage but also you want
to be working nothing wrong with them no no no
no not that how has all rhodes de Pearla changed
your writing process I think since it's one of the
earlier ones and and and and seeing how it could
be developed and into it I think now I'm trying
to get tighter in my storytelling you're trying
to if again back to an athlete analogy an athlete
what could you work on I think it's for writing
for film I i need to be tighter for 90 minutes
for hours to Pearla and other things
I think there's a world where you can
have it like episodic limited series so you
could dive into the characters more on in
I think that's that's what I've kind of
learned if I have a if I have a situation
or an idea that involves tons of characters I
probably would start out writing it as a pilot
and now if I have like a pretty great idea that I
could tell within a film space of like 90 minutes
I'll switch the film I think that's that's how
riding that all roads superior has helped me kind
of kind of divide the the two areas I believe just
to keep them separate because each one has its own
sort of format and and expectations when you say
tighter do you mean that you feel sometimes the
story will meander and you're trying to keep it
on course yeah yeah I think for me personally
I think because I write very visually I think
it's too flowery and I write as a writer director
so there's a lot of things I'm putting on the
page that that I don't need to because I know
I'm going to direct it but I like to write it
and create it for for folks but if I was purely
writing as a writer I get supe a lot tighter
because I i want to experience that in terms
of like not to be to explain things and not have
as much camera direction or setting things up and
flowery I want it tighter so I won't so I could
turn the page that would be my goal now before
I think the goal before was writing something
with with heart now I think maintaining that
but but condensed yeah van if we were going to
get a seven minute lesson from you on writing
a screenplay so I've never written a screenplay
before but I had this movie idea can you help me
write that screenplay in seven minutes not
the actual screenplay instruct me on man I
I'm not one an authority but if I had to if
someone if I was asking myself that when I was
starting what would would I say to my younger self
in seven minutes how to start this what I would
I would first off see what's the story what's
what's the genre and why do you want to tell it
in three words give me three words about the story
it could be just three three words revenge another
word so we'll start with those words then give
me a character who do you want in the character
then I'll go ask okay where's this
take place get the character what's the
character's job what does that person do and
what does that character want to do and then
develop the world develop the character and why
do you want to tell that story and we'll start
from there and then go out go back and then just
even if it's one page or two page or three pages
write something about what this character does
in that world with their job and when what what
they want to do and then once you have that
then we could flesh it out a little bit more
and then then maybe like you said start an outline
what what what do they need what's their obstacles
and and then we add more characters in but I i
would probably start with who the who the main
character is and in the world they're in so
then just quickly I'll give you my character
is a waitress at a greasy spoon diner off route
whatever in texas okay she's 40. she makes decent
wages there it's not really an exciting
job but the owner of a local plant
has said I will make a deal with you and that deal
is I want you to listen to what my employees say
when I'm not there and you're going to report
back and I'm going to put you on payroll
okay all right it seems like there's a lot of
conflict there's some sort of like moral dilemma
as well and you got a character on and then what
and then you could explore explore that explore
the routes of is she a good hearted waitress
is she does she want to become the owner of
this take out the boss or does she want to fight
for who's who's doing who they're listening into
so there's different routes in that so it starts
to what's what's the the the the makeup of this
or our hero or or protagonist because they could
be like the joker he's he you didn't have to be
the best guy but what was this person doing and
so at least you have you have that and you have
that to start and then and then throw throw a
couple obstacles and then and see what happens
because it could lead somewhere else because
you're just you just have an idea you don't
have it yet formed so run with it run with
something run with a direction and maybe write it
and then that might spur spur something
forward hence time back to the daydreaming
because you don't know what it could lead because
you're saying oh actually she's doing this because
she wants to get to new york and because why
because she she her she gave up a daughter and now
that she wants to she wants to go see that because
she only has six months left to live and she wants
to make peace with that daughter and and tell her
things that she she wished that someone told her
something like that so that's just that's the
association disconnect and you could go okay is
that the story you want to tell or or do you
want a a a drama or do you want it a a genre
or a horror film so so you stick stick to that and
that that's where it'll lead and what was the last
part I'm asking myself why do I want to write this
yeah why why I think you should all also ask why
why do you want to write this what like it's
a question where because it's going to drop
drive the narrative because it's that that's the
question and the answer is your your screenplay
because it's it's I think there's something
in that film that you crown you create that
you're trying to investigate so why do you want
to write this what's going on are you trying to
talk about unrequited love are
you going to try to talk about
haunted pass or you're going to try to talk
about what a new way out a new living hope
and things like that so why do you want to talk
about that and it generally has to do sometimes
what's happening in your life right now and it's
because it's easier to because you could feel like
oh I feel like I want to talk about anxiety
the loss of jobs the the loss of the economy
being a new homeowner not knowing if I can make
that how can I synthesize that feeling into the
script of this girl in the diner how to get that
feeling anxiety in there what she's going through
so that's how it would kind of help usher it
along and then just write your first draft and
come with an image you already got the image diner
maybe the opening shot is a bottle of ketchup
who knows and it falls on the floor
and she picks it up and sweeps it away
and then that could be an image a theme that
could that you could hold on to throughout
sparingly so you're not totally spoon
feeding the audience of why is that a ketchup
is she part of the hunts family
who knows do I know the ending
do I need to know it what
if you write three endings
put in a hat and pick one
and then and go from there
so if a lot of times I think for me I have
problems deciding so if there's a course already
set and you have a couple of different things you
could try it but then if it's a course you don't
like you revere back sort of like maybe that's
what I do in my life it's like I'll try it if
I don't like it I'll veer back so that's sort of
like that process of me for writing I'll go down
on the road oh my gosh that dialect's too cheesy
I don't need that character I don't need to talk
to the other waitress I needed to talk to the
mailman that came and gave her a package that
came from new york or something like that so then
the three alternate endings could be she makes her
money she leaves that town she doesn't look back
she sees her daughter she tells her I'm sorry
she has a sense of peace the daughter has a
sense of peace the other ending could be she
meets a good looking drifter and he's a smooth
talker and he says darling I want to take you
to new york I want to see mama meet her
baby and they go she packs he says hang on
I'm going to get smokes at this gas station he
robs it she doesn't know that she's in the car
now she's an accomplice he gets arrested she gets
arrested she goes to prison she dies there third
she's too scared to go the daughter says I don't
don't come and she ends up staying at this diner
and nothing much happens to her and she just
kind of stews in the regret yeah those are great
great great three things see so with even with
that we just spit bald in two three minutes
and just write it a lot of times we'll just sit
there and wait for two months or three months
no this is not working I gotta research this I
gotta do that but if you stick to those feelings
I'm already thinking about the girl oh what if she
came to the diner finally and then like and just
different things so that's what happened that's
sort of what happens and you kind of like go with
it but you never know where it goes unless you
try it so yeah that's good if she shows up yeah
that's it right why'd you give me up right then
you have that awesome or it could be really like
that scene from the rest of the wrestler
when when she she the daughter comes and
talks to Mickey Rourke and that powerful
exchange of like oh things like that so why
or it could be a thriller that she
comes back and poisons her oh gosh yeah
i like it now I want to write this thing yeah
that's good that helped I like to throwing the
three things in there and then some of the other
ideas I wouldn't have thought about the daughter
in new york no you don't that's that's the so
now when you do that when you that's the fun
part when you start then you read it out loud
you're like oh things open up like so that's
why I think it's important to not be holding to
what you've done because it's like you should
feel really good that you've already wrote it
it's out there but if that scene needs to go
it needs to go and a new one could be born that's
that's the whole thing and not be so precious with
with these scenes because I think that's I think
that's the scary part because you well at least
for me I'll talk about me again sometimes you
feel like you can't do it like it won't be as good
or just it won't work or it's you haven't
thought about it because it takes a lot of work
yeah and you brought up stuff that I wasn't
thinking of and so and then I liked it better
what you brought up and and and you
brainstorm yeah yeah what's the title of this
of the let's see I love titles that's the
hardest that's that's one that kind of
what do you what do you feel the title should
be waiting I'm that might be too cliche sorry
but it's also it's not just what she does
but her daughter is waiting for an answer
yeah she's waiting to start her life
so as cliche as it sounds there's many meanings
to that yeah I probably would it takes me longer
with the with the title because that would that's
sort of what would drop would drive it could be
is it more about the daughter or
the mom good question so you know
right I think it's more about the mom yeah
so so pick her middle name and then jolene
she's a southern gal she's a southern belle
maybe she won a beauty contest when she
was younger but she got stuck in this town
and jolene sounds great yeah yeah I think that's a
good sounding name or you could and then you could
add or you could as you as you go maybe it's a
letter that the a phrase a letter that she she had
slipped for the baby whenever she had or something
like that or maybe maybe it's both of their names
jolene and jolene and izzy I like that so
maybe it's about both of them so you and then
you couple them up like them louise and you
have them drive off the cliff sure and then
there's a brad pitt character too yeah gotta have
that one you gotta have that and a dancing scene
every great movie has a dance that's true yeah
and every 80s movie had a great singing scene
you've mentioned previously reading a lot of
screenplays where do you find the screenplays
that you read I whether it's on on the internet
and you just kind of like look for it those
are like established like like screen screen
plays where it's like being in las vegas or or
movies that are coming out for for oscars because
they would release it by the studios or things
like that or the blacklist announcements will
have that I also have worked with a development
for finland entertainment and where I would cover
lots of different screenplays so I get to see and
read tons that aren't they're not produced yet and
things like that so you kind of you kind of get a
a a good or I kind of get a good grasp
of what's what's being out there and
what's been done when you re read your favorite
screenplays and and watch the movies and I think
that's that's a good start do you watch the
movies first or read the screenplay first or it
varies I think it varies but some sometimes
I i prefer the screen the screenplays
because I like to have my own interpretations of
that but there are some like that I've read that
are just really spot on but I love I love reading
screenplays it just kind of flows and you could
you read enough of them I guess you could feel
you could really tell the writer's voice it's
it's it's cool when you do when you do and you
see that and like oh wow that really flows and
the way they use alliteration or there's ways they
use their periods or how they space stuff or how
all these little things because there's not
not much else but the way you move it is
is how it's pretty vital I think that's the
craft of it and and being economical in terms of
describing things and and and it's so true I keep
going back these cliches of like arrive late and
leave early that kind of stuff that you always
hear and it's it's it's hard to do when you're
you're you're kind of in that world in focus
so that's why it's good to just get that first
draft done and then just cut chopping and you
feel you if you miss it and then add it back in
do you ever read non-professional screenplays
yeah yeah yeah I think I mean not as much as
recently of of things but I've read just
different friends and things like that or
last couple years not as much though a lot have
been just from what's out there so to answer that
question I haven't to be honest I haven't read
many non-professional screenplays last like three
years or so yeah what's the difference between
an amateur script and a professional script
they say it's like the first couple pages and um
it's the command of that page the
way you intro a character the way
the world is created the way that um
you turn the page that that's it I don't
know how like when you read something
that makes you want to get up and go to put the
popcorn in the microwave or go make a toast that
happens with professional screenplays too there's
a lot it's hard it's hard to keep someone engaged
for how many like an hour and a half to read if
we read that thing so the difference I would say
is how how they get into the characters build
that world and and have unique voices and make
you want want to care on the page that you could
feel you could see the movie in your head I think
that's that's the thing you've seen something that
you've that you haven't before versus like oh this
reminds me of that or this oh this reminds me of
forrest gump but I think when we first started
on that fault of it too is because we don't we
we're tr we're being influenced and and being
inspired by the things that we like and we come
it comes into our work but that's why if you stick
to the themes you stick to how you express those I
think you can have something more original because
it's your voice it's connected to you personally
so that's the answer it's being personal because
it's something personal to this individual that
I'm I want to experience that I see it on the page
yeah and is that going back to what we talked
about earlier is finding the why yeah I think
so yeah why it's like hey why do I want to to to
write this because there's layers of stuff even
if it's an allegory to this or parallels it's it's
a lot of different things even if it's about space
martians or even it's a fast and furious there's
other things involved why why and then when you
when when you actually read something that drives
you it's because that person has has has made
these characters come alive and you you want to
know what's going to happen so I think that's
that's the difference because it's hard to explain
I guess but when you read it you're like oh
I'm gonna go make coffee instead versus like
when you read something like wait a second
I'm gonna read that if you guys are ever like
back even I took like a lot of english classes
even though I was a business major
I was too lazy to change majors
but I remember reading jude the obscure cut all
day thomas hardy booked like just couldn't put it
down it took me a couple days but I couldn't stop
now imagine a script which is 100 pages so that's
that's the aim and the goal to have to
write something that someone can't put down
not everyone and when there's going to be a
lot of people that hate it a lot of people
love it but there will be a person that's going
to love it and can't put that down that's that's
the kind of that's the goal I think all right judy
bloom books yeah yeah couldn't just turn down they
were all excellent yeah definitely how do you
work with actors and actually more specifically
how does your process working with actors evolve
from the audition to them working with them on
set yeah great that's that's fun part working
with actors they're they're I mean actors so
talented they you want to create opportunities
for them to perform at their highest level and
from for our for our purposes for all roads of
Pearla we there's no rehearsals they just can't
they come and just nail it it's just just the way
just how how they are but each one is each actor
is different it's like being a coach again from a
team each player is motivated in certain ways each
character is developing certain things your my job
as a director for me is to provide them a place to
try things to to get into that character and to
elevate what's on on that script and I think that
that's the key to to have them add their
special sauce to this dish because even if
the way someone says two words by the way their
eyes twitch could say a lot and it's because
they're feeling that character and that they're
not walking through they're not just dialed in
because I that's what makes them great it's versus
someone who's reading lines you could feel that's
that's their gift to to perform and make that
character emote so as a writer you try to give
them the words to do that but as a performer
and as a director I just get out of the way
and go hey let's take another take I know it's
so easy hey try this it's a matter of having a
director's that job is it's like it's a taste
you direct things you say this but you just got
to give the actor that that that luxury some
people need something to hold some people need
this so you have to know what each actor needs
and give that to them so from audition to screen
again I was lucky to be working with stellar
actors for the first time professional actors who
who have been doing this for years addison's
was his she's was acting for decades
dash my hock decades so it's me just for them to
love the script and and run with it and that's the
that's the key get that script so they they they
feel like they could add something to it so the
delivery of lines little facial micro expression
exactly something twitch in the eye twitch
and here's the best part that they do it over and
over again the exact same way so when you edit
it's almost seamless that's a professional that's
what they're giving you that that opportunity in
the edit room to use takes that are just great
but they do it in a way where it's just not like
my hair is blown this way or this hair this or
the shirt or things and just that professionalism
and understanding what the character needs
but then just delivering in that you know
in a hot room but no ac
after 12 hours yeah yeah how does the director
build strong relationships with actors
for a first time future director
I mean I would be nervous
but the only commodity I had was the script
and everyone who was working there um
liked the script before they liked me so I i
had nothing to do with do with that personally
in terms of like me but for me to gain like the
trust of the actors is I think it was a lot of
my train like training and being a portrait
photographer we talked about before is is
we have to give ourselves and and and be
vulnerable even to the crew as well everyone
it's not like I'm gonna walk on the set and
say I'm martin scorsese or or whatever it's
like I'm the least experienced person on set thank
goodness because and just be honest with that but
but I know the story I know it's inside and out
I'm here to make and have this vision and you I'm
here to work with you guys to create something
I can't even imagine what's that's in my head
so you you set that out and hopefully the team
follows and then they build and you and each day
you work for their respect you work and show
it it doesn't happen the first day first week
it it happens through time just like relationships
um and and and I and I'm i'm one to always maybe
I'm gonna be grown up as a people pleaser so it's
harder and like oh okay do you need this or that
or so I'm always on edge so but but I hope to
start like that but it's a fine line too you
want it you you run you run the ship too you want
you don't want it you want to make sure things are
going accordingly and and and not be a pushover
in terms of of of your vision and you could take
lots of ideas and lots of things and and you'd be
dumb not to but in the end of the day you have to
take all that information you have to decide
what is best for for the story and you get to
make that decision and you live and die with it
you know so as a director you get a lot of credit
but you shouldn't because it takes 140 people
40 people to 100 feet to make it but if movies
is not as successful you go down with it
too but that's what you sign up for I guess
did you sell finance all roads to perrla actually
we financed our perler with private equity on tax
in debt so a bank and then that's the
three components how we we got it so we
had investors and then we we shot in oklahoma
that gave us a a 32 tax incentive to shoot pair
and then we made up that tax incentive
through through financing through through
through a bank loan with that so that's how
we came up with the budget and we're able to
hit the ground in oklahoma because of that yeah
so what happens first the self-financing you
have like your own little chunk and then
you decide what state you want to go to
and go to their film commission or yeah so so
you could go like atlanta on new mexico louisiana
it's just all depends and then you you have
to go to the film commission you you file
an application you gotta if you it meets all the
requirements and even while you're in production
you have to keep really good books and and records
and there's gonna be a third party audit and all
these different things before so it's pretty
extensive and you want to have that covered
and of that but if you were to shoot whether
it's in california vancouver for you for for
producers out there that are trying to raise a
dollar having a tax incentive you really need
to raise 68 cents to the dollar so that's what
really what that meant because you're spending
in that state and you're also hiring the crew in
that there's supposed to be a percentage of cast
and crew that is from that that state to to follow
the rules of the the tax incentives so each each
state will have their own like new york and new
mexico and things like that so it's really I think
right now even in australia or new zealand because
of the pandemic dimmick I think their incentives
if I read correctly was like 50 or something now
so wow they're just trying to get production going
and then tell me about this loan oh so so let's
let's say let's say your budget is 10 million
dollars and you're shooting in oklahoma
and they're going to give you 32
so really effectively you only have to raise
6.8 million right so so but to make the full
10 million you don't get that money right away
you need to make up that sort of gap and and
things so someone you need to get a collateral or
loan to to make the 10 million the 3.2 million so
that would be a bank or whoever could give you
that that's what debt or maybe there's another
person that's going to loan you that money but
that's going to be debt so that's what that's
what happened so after you finish shooting after
you do the audit then you get the money back from
oklahoma after you file everything
then you could pay back the debt
and that's a gap loan on that too that's a
little bit that that's a little bit different
oh I see okay okay so it sounds like you can't
get one without the other so you couldn't just
go and say hey I want to shoot here and I want
incentives but then you don't have your own
quote unquote equity deposit that you're putting
in you've got to have that first is that right
because you can't go without any of your own money
in or is that well you can't it it just depends
because if you want the full budget because that
includes post-production deliverables and things
if you're an independent producer and you have
just enough to to get into production maybe do
another fundraise or another raise later
to finish the movie called finishing funds
just just in case because if you just want to get
like in production you could raise the production
budget post-production money could be raised later
it just all depends on how you how you do it for
instance it costs to color the film to make dcps
to to get an editor things all that that's the all
the po the compo composer sound sound mix but if
you just have enough money to get into production
a lot a lot of it just depends on your you and
your producers and how you feel about that it's
it's tricky it's definitely you wanna you want the
full budget but if you have enough just to get in
production and then the actors are only available
that time period you never know if it's gonna go
so you're like hey let's just get let's get just
get on the ground and shoot so theoretically can
you approach a film commission for to apply for
for incentives before you have any budget raised
they'll they'll ask you if you if you do
they'll that they'll you you you got to show
how much on capital and equity that you've raised
and things I didn't fill that out part out so the
other producers did but I'm not specific on the
oklahoma thing but but we had raised the equity
to get yeah to get there and then and then you
have to leave show your bank statements and
things like that so so they know hey you're just
going to say hey I have the budget and then you
get there and you don't and things like that so
yeah they they have their vetting process as well
and you had originally wanted to shoot in texas
correct that's correct yeah and and that's because
the film's set in texas I was I had scouted in
fort worth and and things but on just strictly
because of the tax incentive and we just drove
up three hours on having the same landscape and
and and we were able to shoot in oklahoma instead
yeah how did you pitch the company that helped
you finance all roads to polo I met red sanders
of red entertainment red productions through a
composer our composer named curtis heath who
did a lot of my short films and they were in for
fort worth and I was scouting in down there
and he was like hey have you talked to red
entertainment I was like no I haven't and then
they have offices in santa monica and I was in la
at the time and sent over an email and said hey
we have a mutual friend curtis I've got the script
that I'm gonna be doing and they they read it
loved it we had a meeting and I loved people
from texas and then they were like sweethearts and
they were just great and derek and red are just
fantastic folks and then I had I
had my mood reel I had my lookbook
I had pretty much things this in the
things set up and they they liked it
and then I eventually became with gopot films and
red productions and we we held sort of certain
meetings for investors and things like that but
eventually we we cobbled up the financing through
separate investors and got that all done red and
derrick were instrumental in lifting the project
even further in getting the script to lindsey
graham who who worked at betty may casting and
she was just finished casting like a star is born
and suicide squad and things like that and and and
bigger features but she she like really liked
the script and came on board and that through
that through that our project picked up steam and
we were able to that's how we were able to get
actors to respond and things like that and and and
that's how we got lucky in terms of nailing some
of these really like dash and addison and alex
and the whole crew there so through with without
that involvement without red and derrick and and
lindsay I would have been just shooting already
Pearla with my father in there acting so uh
somehow it just swims up and then mind you we
also approached other tons of other production
companies who who we wanted to partner up with
but you get hey we don't get the script this is
not for us or we have a similar project or it's
lots of things so that's why I even sit back
here today just thinking it's a miracle that it
it's even out there for people to see so so it
goes back to that question when is it good or
crap charles pakowski and I was like man
after just going through this gauntlet I'll re
reserve my opinions to myself do why some
of the investors passed did they give you
when when these were people I know you said that
they had said it might be similar to something
I already have or it's not for them but when
red sent it out to the people in his network
yeah I again I it has to do with subject matter
it has to do with connection has to do with people
connecting it like or people wanting to change
the story or people want to do this or or does
it resonate so back to your question go why do you
want to write this so you have to find people that
kind of falls in that wheelhouse that believes the
same way you do our film is is about love and pain
loss love lust it's it's it's a dark and gritty
film and it's not not for everyone it's it's
to me there's messages of hope but to others they
might see an ugly side of society that doesn't hit
especially especially so when an investor reads
it are they going to connect connect with this so
so you they either do or they don't and you you
go into the next person who who connects with it
and and and find that so if you're out there it's
just like first you have to champion yourself
then find people that would help champion you
and then and then keep going I think that's
the steps when you're dealing with production
companies investors what do they want to see
first a log line synopsis of the script yeah so
basically basically on log line gets everyone if
you make a killer log line I know it's it's hard
one two sentences your pitch deck your lookbook
your mood reel to for them to get them excited
to read the script no one wants to read anything
so that's the problem there's just
a lot of scripts so how do you get
people to read it so you have to entice them
whether it's through that log line through the
look book through the mood reel through
whoever's already attached or an actor
or producer it just has to and that's what they
call it a package I guess you package things so
it makes them it makes it harder for
them to say no so that's what I would do
as much as you can so start definitely start with
the lookbook so least it gives you an idea of of
what the story is about the mood and tone and
then you don't want to give a crime thriller to
family drama production company unless they want
to branch off and do something different because
they're used to doing that so just maybe research
comparable films and what production companies
that have produced that in that particular budget
level and then approach them things like that so
imdb pros will be your friend and and just
research and then and then just send out and and
I hope someone reads it it took me five years so
can you describe the all roads to perrla lookbook
how many images are were in it how many pages
all right so basically it's like a powerpoint
presentation I think mine had like 12 pages and
I'll say the I'll have a picture the color palette
the tone pictures from from a lot of the pictures
because I had photographed already because of my
my photography so it's already a world that I've
already created then I would add the log line the
tone the theme and then and then that's the feel
the visuals of it what this movie would look like
I just and then I had a mood reel so what
that meant was I i clipped together films
and music and made like a trailer of how the
film would look like it's interesting because
I just looked at my mood reel that I created
I hadn't looked in ages and you should see
it through the trailer right now five years apart
to see the the difference it's pretty fascinating
and our composer and not the sound designer
was like man oh my god just saw that mood
reel that dance scene looks almost identical
to what we shot I didn't know what was what
it's kind of fascinating so if you could
show what the what the world you're creating
already without shooting it you don't it's a
quicker way than creating a short film to to
to create that atmosphere at least it will give
you entice you to read the script that's all I
wanted someone to do but they knew I knew how to
make visuals I knew how to make sound now you just
judge me on my narrative writing so that was my
thought process and how long is the mood reel
it's like two minutes two minutes or two
minutes and 30 seconds something like that
or a previous they call it a previous two so
I do that now like if they send me like if
like a manager just send you scripts to read
and it's something you like and you want to
be up for it to direct oh yeah that's a great
script that's fantastic I'll quickly throw up
a mood wheel and go this is how I see the film
this is what I'll do the tone and mood of it
so from understanding correctly it was about three
to four years of this process of you sending out
the lookbook the mood reel the packaging for
all roads superla how many people did you
actually send it to and what was their response
time how many actually read the screenplay
I have an excel spreadsheet of everyone who I
would send it to I don't remember I don't I i
know I kept it because I like to keep track of it
a lot of people did not read or did not respond
the majority majority of it I was even
determined to shoot it no matter what
it was of that fateful sort of it only took
one which was red productions so maybe out of
50 to 100 red productions or I'm just I'm
just throwing another I know it was pretty
red productions came on and even after red came on
we went to bigger production companies to kind of
get involved and that was pretty much
turned down turned down too so we just
did it on our own so that process I couldn't even
get my friends to read it I couldn't get fam like
it's that's when no one likes to read anything
even even what have you it's it's it's it's
that's why it's a miracle that derek was like
read it and loved it so it just took it was like
oh what is the story and what's that so to one
did it took we I submitted it for quite a few
and it was really just one or two that responded
and then that was it that's all it kind of took
knowing this knowing that it's very difficult to
get anybody to read a script is there anything
you think you could do to speed up this process
the next time around I think the next time around
it's it's it's getting easier but I think most
people don't make it to the next time around so
the first time around I don't think there is I
think it's just because we're saturated and even
it's like you just it's like I always go back to
that denzel washington quote you stick around the
barber shop long enough you're going to get a
haircut so no matter it's the third rejection
the 100th or the 400th you just got to stick
it out and then you're going to get frustrated
you can just get tired and go I don't need to
wait for anyone I don't need this production
company say yes I'm going to do it and then you
set a date once I set a date that's when I got
phone calls when I said november 13th a
specific date I'm shooting no matter what
this train is going then it started even
with actors and even with this stuff so
you have to be very specific can't go I'm shooting
in the fall I'm shooting november 13th even at 2
p.m we were rolling first night things like
that that helped because that made it real
who it was important to me it made it real for
me so I was like then whoever I said that to
I'm doing it and then so that's why I was like
gosh I'm either delusional or naive or but I think
you have to so that's that's sort of what happened
so I i don't know if I could do anything different
and the other part that you said most people
don't they don't get a second time to do this
i was just looking at the numbers of something so
someone sent the numbers after your first feature
was like 17 percent for so that's not the majority
especially when you have investors and people
so that's my saying as a producer to
have sustainable career is to make the
investors money back it's not about art
as a director you might be able to but
that's the fear and you look at the stats and
what's happening so you have to mitigate that risk
you have to figure out ways to maneuver that and
that's that's the business side that's that's not
going hey this frame looks awesome oh that's
a great color color the makeup and this it's
how we can do this again and how can we deliver
it and how can we shoot it in time and how we
get it under budget that's just the reality
of it and and that's the brutal part of it
unless you shoot it with your iphone and and
and and which is great and you have crew but
there's only certain amount of
favors you could call you you
don't want to not pay people to to work they're
long hard hours and what they do they do it's
there's there's only so much I just feel that's
just me personally you don't I don't want to be
a production company it doesn't pay people
to not do that everyone needs to be paid so
there's it takes a lot of people to make
something and that adds up to the budget
so would you say it's easier for you to get your
emails returned now that you have an excellent
body of work to point to yeah I think so because
you you have that first first feature kind of done
so now they can't say oh he hasn't done a first
feature but now they could say but he hasn't
done a thriller there's always something but the
whole name of the game I think what's important
is if it gives you confidence it gave me
confidence to keep going so all these little
wins so if you get any little wind any little
thing keep it because there's just so many losses
so you could get these this confidence to keep
going now because of our perlis sleeping plastic
on script I got management opportunity in
there and there and I had three other scripts
ready to rock and roll and a tv pilot so I'm
waiting on this I wanted to make sure I'm not
when opportunity to meet you are you talking to
people oh what are you doing after this I'm not
fumbling and going oh I'm working on something
I was like here here you go I've got tons left
and I wanted it to create a situation where it
was hard to people harder for people to say no
like I don't want to wait around because you're
waiting around all all these years so all that
anxiety made me write and and do all these kinds
of things so I wanted to make sure I had things so
so I was able to get reps and then they
they now help push prod the projects
and things and and thankful for
that in terms of of of trying to
climb this hill of who what of creation
of of getting projects made so I'm still
learning each day this whole thing so which
which yeah it's fun did you approach gravitas
or did they approach you we had so we have a sales
agent prince films and who their their duty is to
get it try to get their film sold to
different territories and things and I think
gravitas uh igor prince reached out to gravitas
and then they they made an offer that that was
suitable for us and then that was for north
america so it's being distributed through
offstring platforms cable and things we had a
limited theatrical release plan but in l.a in new
york but that got squashed but but again we're
super thankful for for just to reach daylight
considering considering what so many
other filmmakers are going through and
having their feelings showing up this
year and not even going to the festival
festival route with all the virtual festivals
and things like that we were lucky to
start our festival last year run and then it ended
earlier because of pandemic so but but we were
able to get north american distribution did you
have to sell the film in any way to gravitas or
because you went through this sales agent it
yeah so you kind of sort of you have your film
and you you could either sell it through
different territories or worldwide and so igor he
he does the dealings for that you can go to
gravitas yourself I believe or any distributor
for that matter you don't it's I would
equate it to having if you built a house
you could sell your house by yourself or you could
get a realtor they get a commission things things
of that sort so usually when you have sales reps
and they have relationships prior to the because
you're bombarded usually by a lot of films some
people answer the phone more than others and and
then igor took our film through all the different
markets toronto can different things so they would
have booths set up and and film buyers would
take a look and things like that so that's the
advantage I would say with having a sales agent
who is there to help push the sale of your film
but we went with gravitas because they had
good favorable terms they were they were
they're nice folks and and it was also a situation
where we we still have international rights
as well as well how has covet impacted your
filmmaking career let's see I think just in terms
of in in general this personally and professional
it's puts puts everyone at a pause to we talked
about earlier like to see what is important in
life what what what do we want to do it kind of
makes you think about those kinds of things how
how it personally has affected my filmmaking life
is I think when you go through the process
of owning a business or trying to make a film
there's always a monkey wrench and if you could
survive the monkey wrench and it hasn't hurt
hasn't taken your legs out and and and you're
still standing you keep trudging along there's
whether and I try to have that state of mind and
mentality okay if I can't do this then there's
something else I can do while this is happening
I could write I could research I could think of
ideas I could chill out balance life maybe spend
more time with family more not be so self-absorbed
and go go go so so those are the things that we
all have to question ourselves every day and then
and then I was just talking with my wife the other
day it's like feels like I've been running for 10
10 10 years running and it just feels weird
to not run because you're just so used to it
then but sometimes you need just to relax
and take it take it off and recharge and and
think about others beside yourself and your
career and what you want to do and and it's like
that's that's I hope to try to be better
at in in and and as we all try to navigate
these crazy times and so yeah I hope we
like I said we still have our pencil and
and notepad and final draft and we could still
keep writing yeah sorry I have to bring up this
it's cliche but just the scene in forrest gump
where he's running and everyone's like oh he
stopped okay wait hang on hang on he's gonna
speak he's gonna speak and then all he just
says is I'm tired now I think I'm gonna go home
yeah that's like that's I mean yeah that movie is
excellent in every single way and it because it's
because those those scenes those moments relatable
it's it's like that's why all these great the
great songwriters are great screenwriters they
they do something so simple and it makes you
feel like you can do it and that's the best part
to write a song to make you want to go and learn
how to play a guitar that's amazing for everyone
so that to have forrest gump or princess
bride or do these things you're like hey
yeah that's something I want to do whether we ever
achieve that that that's not the case it's just
I do you want to give it a shot and I think
kind of for those who even were thinking it's
difficult out there to try to be a filmmaker
just find your half-price books and buy a book
and read and write and and don't don't think
about what's happening in 10 years think about
if it makes you happy today and if you could
write a story I think that's the important part.
What did you love most about Van’s story?